ALMOST UP SO WE WILL NOW COME
TO ORDER. AND IN RESPONSE TO
THE COVETED NINETEEN EMERGENCY
TO PROTECT OUR PUBLIC THE
SENATORS AND STAFF WE'RE
LIMITING NONESSENTIAL
GATHERINGS AND HEARING TO
PERSONAL DISTANCING IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THESE ORDERS
THE SENATE WILL BE HOLDING AN
ESSENTIAL HEARING WHICH IS
THIS. WE'VE MADE. THIS IS
TWENTY THE POP. TO HAVE ACCESS
TO OUR PROCESS WILL CONDUCTING
THE HEARING IN A WAY THAT
PROTECTS OUR HEALTH. TO ALLOW
THE UBLIC ACCESS WE'VE
ADMITTED MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
TO TWO HEARING ROOMS TO THE
EXTENT THAT SOCIAL DISTANCE
REQUIREMENTS TO ALLOW. AND WE
WILL BE USING A TELECONFERENCE
SERVICE FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS
WHO WISH TO TESTIFY TODAY. FOR
ALL INDIVIDUALS WISHING COOPER
HI BUT COMMENT ON IT THE BILL
BUT WE'LL BE HEARING. THE
PARTICIPANT TOLD HER IN PERSON
CODE IS POSTED ON THE WEBSITE.
IT WILL BE DISPLAYED ON THE
SCREEN AND I WILL ANNOUNCE IT.
THE NUMBER IS. PARTICIPANTS
WANT TO TESTIFY ONE. SEVEN
SEVEN THREE THREE SIX FOUR FOUR
ONE. ACCESS CODE. SIX SEVEN
SEVEN FIVE ZERO SIX NINE. WHEN
WE MOVED TO PUBLIC COMMENT. A
MODERATE WILL IDENTIFY YOU
INDIVIDUALLY OPEN YOUR LINE
THIS IS FOR THOSE OF YOU ON THE
PHONE AND AT THAT TIME YOU MAY
ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE PLEASE
NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR US TO
HEAR YOU CLEARLY. THE DEVICE
YOU ARE WATCHING. THE HEARING
ON PRIOR TO GIVING YOUR
TESTIMONY. TO IMPORTANT WE HEAR
FROM YOU THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE- I WILL MAINTAIN
DECORUM DURING THE HEARING AS
IS CUSTOMARY ANY INDIVIDUALS
WHO ARE DISRUPTIVE MAY BE
REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE MEETING
SERVICE OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED. WHILE EVERY
EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINED HEARING PROCESSING
CONDUCTOR HEARINGS IN AS CLOSE
TO THE SAME MANNER AS USUAL
THERE MAY BE SOME LAG TIME IS.
SPENT TOUR ADJUSTING. THE USE
OF THE NEW ON LINE TECH TOOLS
AND TECHNOLOGIES. I'M SORRY
PROCEED YOUR PATIENTS. WE HAVE
ELEVEN BILLS ON TODAY'S AGENDA.
THERE ARE FOUR PROPOSED FOR
CONSENT AND BEFORE WE HEAR THE
PRESENTATION ON THE BILL'S
LET'S STAFF WHICH QUORUM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
INNER I HEAR DINNER HERE BUT
YES EMPLOYEES THOSE OF YOU WHO-
WHEN YOU SAY HERE PLEASE MAKE
SURE YOU HAVE HIT YOUR
MICROPHONE. IT'S THE ONLY WAY
THAT YOU CAN BE RECORDED AS
BEING PRESENT GO AHEAD KEEP
GOING WARLOCK. PRESENT MORE
LIKE PRESENT. BRADFORD PRESENT
JACKSON THIS IS. JACKSON
PRESENT MITCHELL HERE. MITCHELL
HERE MORALE HEARD ME ALWAYS
FEEL WIENER. THE COURT RIGHT
FORM HAS BEEN ESTABLISHED- MAY
I HAVE A MOTION ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. GREAT SIDE WE CAN
ALWAYS ADD FOLKS ON THE ROLE OF
A MISDEMEANOR THIS IS A MOTION
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR. THERE
ARE FOUR BILLS PROPOSED FOR
CONSENT. AND WE HAVE THE MOTION
SO- I WILL TAKE ROLL CALL ON
THE MOTION SKINNER THE I CAN OR
I MORE LOCK. FIVE MORE LOCKED
BRADFORD HEADFORD I'D JACKSON
ALL RIGHT JACKSON AYE MITCHELL
AYE MITCHELL AYE WIENER. AND
MORALE BUT WE ARRIVE AROUND. BY
WILL HOLD THE ROLE OPEN FOR ME
AS A SENATOR RURAL FEE ARRIVES
IN THE OTHERWISE THERE ARE
ENOUGH VOTES FOR THE CONSENT
CALENDAR BUT WE WILL WILL DRAW
OPENS SO WE WILL NOW HEAR FROM
OUR- USE ME FIRST AUTHOR.
SENATOR OR TWO LETTER YOU MAY
PRESENT YOUR BILL SB NINE ZERO
FIVE. GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS- I'M SO PROUD TO BE
HERE WITH YOU THIS MORNING TO A
VERY IMPORTANT BILL. ONCE AGAIN
THANK YOU- I AM HERE TO PRESENT
SENATE BILL NINE OH FIVE THE
BACKGROUND CHECKS SECURITY AT.
CALIFORNIA LAW ALLOWS
ORGANIZATIONS TO REQUEST ALL OF
AN APPLICANT'S RECORDSOF
CONVICTIONS FROM CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE IF THE
APPLICANT WOULD HAVE SUPERVISOR
OR DID DISPLAY EVERY POWER.
OVER MINOR OR ANOTHER IN THEIR
CARE. THIS MEASURE IS PRUDENT
STEP IN ENSURING THE SAFETY OF
MINERS AND OTHER VULNERABLE
INTO INDIVIDUALS. HOWEVER THESE
REQUESTS CAN BE EXPLOITED TO
DIVULGE THE LOCATION OF
UNDOCUMENTED INDIVIDUALS THAT
ARE APPLYING TO VOLUNTEER IN
THEIR COMMUNITIES. THE
BACKGROUND CHECKS CAN
POTENTIALLY BE USED TO
DISSEMINATE PERSONAL
INFORMATION WITHOUT PROPER
WARRANT CONSTITUTING AN
UNLAWFUL SEIZURE. THE FEAR OF
THIS PERSONAL INFORMATION BEING
TAKEN HAS CREATED A CHILLING
EFFECT ON THE VOLUNTEER EFFORTS
OF ORGANIZATIONS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE. SOME INDIVIDUALS ARE
AFRAID OF VOLUNTEERING AND
CONTRIBUTING AND THEIR
COMMUNITIES OF FEAR OF THEIR
PRIVACY BEING PREACHED BY
FEDERAL ENTITIES. DURING THIS
CALL BUT NINETEEN CRISIS WE
NEED VOLUNTEERS MORE THAN EVER.
ESPECIALLY NOW PEOPLE SHOULD BE
NOT BE HELD BACK FROM
PROCEDURES FROM CONTRIBUTING TO
THEIR COMMUNITIES. SB NINE OH
FIVE PROTECT THE PRIVACY OF
CALIFORNIANS BY NO LONGER
REQUIRING A RESIDENCE ADDRESS
ON THE BACKGROUND CHECK. BY NOT
REQUIRING AN ADDRESS ON THE
BACKGROUND CHECKS WE CAN
PROVIDE INSURANCE TO
INDIVIDUALS THAT THEY CAN
VOLUNTEER IN THEIR COMMUNITIES
WITHOUT RISKING AND
COMPROMISING THE SAFETY AND
SECURITY OF THEMSELVES OR THEIR
LOVED ONES. THE BILL WOULD ALSO
PROHIBITTHE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE FOR
PROVIDING ANY INFORMATION
RELATED TO THESE BACKGROUND
INQUIRY TO OTHER ENTITIES.
INCLUDING GOVERNMENTAL ENTITIES
ABSENT OF A COURT ORDER OR A
WARRANT. SB NINE OH FIVE DOES
NOT OBSTRUCTED SORTIES IN THEIR
DUTY TO KEEP KIDS SAFE FROM
PREDATORS. IN FACTSB NINE OH
FIVE WOULD INTRODUCE A
UNIVERSAL TYPES I TAKE BACKDROP
LANGUAGE. FBI STANDARDS
SIMPLIFY THE PROCESS AND
REDUCING THE NUMBER OF REQUESTS
FOR FEDERAL CRIMINAL RECORDS
THAT ARE DENIED BY THE FBI. SB
FIVE EDGE TO THE EXISTING
PRIVACY PROTECTIONS OF CITIZENS
AND UNDOCUMENTED IMMIGRANTS
ALIKE WITHIN THE STATE WITHOUT
IMPENDING THE ABILITY OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE TO
INVESTIGATE INTERACTING
AFFORDABLE POPULATIONS. FOR ANY
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS TODAY I
HAVE EDU REVERSE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR CALIFORNIA CATHOLIC
CONFERENCE AND MARTIN WRETCHED
WHICH FROM THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S OFFICE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT VIA THE TELECONFERECE
LINE. RESPECT ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE UNDER ARCHULETA WILL YOU
BE TAKING THE AMENDMENT IN THE
ANALYSIS AND- BELIEVE THAT
THERE WAS AN AMENDMENT TO AGREE
TO. YES MA'AM. SO DO YOU WILL
BE TAKEN OUT AMENDMENT. OKAY SO
IT. WILL BE FOR US WITH DAMON.
OUR RATE LET US HAVE OUR FIRST
WITNESS TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
UNLESS YOU'RE ONLY HERE TO ASK
QUESTIONS ANSWER QUESTIONS. THE
ALRIGHT SO WE. WE WILL INSTEAD
OPEN IT UP TO ANY WITNESSES N.
D. I'M. ROOM IN HERE IN ROOM
FOR TWO OR THREE. WITH A. SORRY
MY. OUR WITNESSES ARE IN THE
OTHER ROOM. ACT NO PHONE TWO
EVEN ARE OKAY ALL ON HOST LINE
I GET IT EXCUSE ME APOLOGIES IT
IS WRITTEN THERE. ALL RIGHT SO
OUR FIRST WITNESS AMBER RIVAS
IS ON THE HOST LINE. THE TOTAL
FOR THE IN FAVOR SIDE BEFORE
OPEN TO THE PUBLIC IS THREE
MINUTES SO WE'LL START WITH
ANDREW RIVAS AND THEN WE'LL
FOLLOW WITH MARTIN MR READ OF
STRETCHED. AND YOUR THE TOTAL
BETWEEN YOU BOTH IS THREE
MINUTES FIVE GO AHEAD FOR THAT-
DOES TO ON THE HOST LOT. THANK
YOU THAT IS THE RESULT OF THIS
YOUR LINES ARE OPEN PLEASE
PROCEED THANK. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND THANK YOU MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE FOR ALLOWING ME
TO SPEAK TODAY MY NAME IS
ANDREW RIVAS AND THE CALIFORNIA
CATHOLIC CONFERENCE RECOGNIZES
THIS UP CAN CHALLENGE TIME IN
OUR HISTORY. AND THE INCREASE
NECESSITY PROVIDING KEY
BUSINESS FOR MILLION IN OUR
STATE. WHETHER THIS CRISIS THIS
IS WHY THE CALIFORNIA CATHOLIC
CONFERENCE SUPPORT. NINE OH
FIVE NOW MORE THAN EVER. THE
MAN FALLING TEARS HAS INCREASED
TREMENDOUSLY FOR THE PAST WEEK.
MANY LIKE OUR CAT AND SHE-
REQUIRE VOLUNTEERS TO UNDERGO
FINGERPRINTING AND BACKGROUND
CHECKS IN ORDER TO ENSURE THE
SAFETY OF THE CHILDREN AND
YOUTH. CSUS WITHOUT SB NINE OF
THE STATE WOULD BE LIMITING THE
NUMBER OF VOLUNTEERS WHICH
LIMITS THE SUPPORT WE CAN
PROVIDE TO OUR COMMUNITIES
DURING CULVERT NINETEEN. ARE
UNDOCUMENTED BROTHERS AND
SISTERS WERE AMONG THOSE NEEDED
SERVICES AND THEY ARE THOSE.
I'M HERE THE SHIFT ALL. MANY OF
WHOM DO BY A CHARITIES WE NEED
NINE OH FIVE NOW FOR TWO
REASONS ONE TO CONTINUE TO
PROMOTE SAFE ENVIRONMENT FOR
CHILDREN BY CONTINUING TO
REQUIRE FINGERPRINTS AND BACK
CHECKS ON ALL. AND TO
PROTECTING THE PRIVACY RIGHTS
OF ALL CALIFORNIANS WHO DO WANT
TO VOLUNTEER. IT CAN HELP THEIR
COMMUNITIES AT A TIME WHEN WE
TRY TO EXTEND OUR SOCIAL SAFETY
NETS TO ALL CALIFORNIANS WE
SHOULD ALSO DO WHAT WE CAN
PROTECT THEIR PRIVACY AND
ENABLE THEM TO VOLUNTEER NOT
COMMUNITIES WITH TRANQUILITY.
REASONS I AM FOR YOUR VOTE TO
IMMEDIATELY IMPACTED SUPPORT.
VOLUNTEERING CHARITY SUPPORT
NEED FOR OUR COMMUNITIES THANK
YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU AND NOW
GOOD MORNING. MR. RED IS RICH
IF YOU ARE. HE WENT TO ADD OR
ANY MONEY IN PARTNER DR RICH.
BUT WITH THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE. ERNIE
GENERAL'S OFFICE IS PLEASED TO
SUPPORT SB NINE OH FIVE IN THE
BEHALF OF ATTORNEY GENERAL
BECERRA I WANT TO THANK SENATOR
ARCHULETA FOR INCLUDING THE
AMENDMENT WHICH WILL ALLOW THE
DOJ TO CONTINUE PROVIDING
FEDERAL CREDIT HISTORY RECORD
INFORMATION OR C. H. R. I.
WELCOME TO BE BACK THANKS FOR.
BEING IN EMPLOYMENT EDUCATION
PER. CALIFORNIA DOJ. YEAH I
SAID THE MAIN THING POINT. IN
CALIFORNIA FOR ENTITIES SEEKING
TO OBTAIN A FEDERAL C. H. R. I.
FOR LICENSING PURPOSES. EACH
TIME A NEW STATUTES ENACTED OR
ANY EXISTING THAT YOU TO THE
MANDATE. THAT REQUIRED THE DOJ
TO PROVIDE TO C. H. R. I. DOJ
BUT AND SEEK APPROVAL FROM THE
ACT I WHICH THEN BEAR BY THE
STATUTE MEET THE REQUIREMENTS
OF THEIR PUBLIC LAW NINETY TWO
FIVE FOUR FOUR. PUBLIC LAW
NINETY FIVE FOUR FOUR INCLUDES
ADMINISTRATIVE SAFEGUARDS FOR
THE DISSEMINATION OF THIS
INFORMATION- AS WELL AS- WELL
AS WELL AS POP RIGHT YEAH THE
I. TO EXCHANGE THIS INFORMATION
WITH. WITH STATE AND LOCAL
OFFICIALS. THE IN UNIVERSE
CITATION IDENTIFIED CONSISTENT
PROCEDURES FOR AGENCIES AND
ORGANIZATIONS TO REQUEST.
INFORMATION FROM THE DOJ IN THE
FBI. AND OF INCLUDING THE
SPECIFIC LANGUAGE IN THE
STATUTE AGENT RELATIONS WILL
NOW BE ABLE TO REFERENCE THIS
NEW STATUTES. ERNIE GENERAL BUT-
PROVISION OF THE BILL AND IT
WHICH WILL PRESERVE ACCESS TO
FEDERAL CRIMINAL HISTORY
INFORMATION FOR IMPROVED
SCREENING OF PEOPLE IN
POSITIONS OF TRUST THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THAT WAS EXACTLY THE
THREE MINUTES SURE YOUR
ARGUMENTS SO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR THAT. WE WILL- MOVE
NOW TO WITNESSES ANY WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT WHO ARE HERE IN ROOM
FOR TWO OR THREE. AND YOU ARE
ALLOWED TO GIVE YOUR- NAME AND
AFFILIATION AND INDICATE
SUPPORT OR NOT SO IS THERE
ANYONE HERE AND FOR TWO OR
THREE TO IS TO- SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF SB NINE OH FIVE.
THIRTEEN NINE. ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY
WHO WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
SB NINE OH FIVE. RIGHT SEEING
NINE. FIVE WE WILL MOVE TO. THE
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION IF
THERE ARE ANY. THERE IS AN
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION ON THE
PHONE. IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK OUT
IN SUPPORT OPPOSITION ON THE
PHONE PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN.
ONE MOMENT PLEASE. THERE'S NO
WITNESS IN OPPOSITION BUT I
FORGOT TO ASK THEIR ANY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT ON THE
PHONE. THERE'S NO ONE QUEUING
UP FOR SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION ON
THE PHONE AT THIS TIME PLEASE
CONTINUE. ALRIGHT THANK YOU
PAUL JEEZ I FORGOT THAT PART.
ALRIGHT SO LET US SEE IF THERE
ARE ANY QUESTIONS FROM ANY OF
THE MEMBERS ON THE DíAS. EN
RELATIONSHIP SB NINE OH FIVE.
EITHER TO THE AUTHOR OR TO THE
TWO PRINCIPAL WITNESSES ANY
QUESTIONS. OF SEEING NINE TIMES
THEN- CENTER TO LETTER DO YOU
WANT TO CLOSE OUT YES MANAGER
THANK YOU ONCE AGAIN IT'S A
VERY IMPORTANT BILL IT WILL
ALLOW PEOPLE TO COME OUT AND
HELP THEIR COMMUNITIES AND IT'S
SO IMPORTANT AND I RESPECT SB I
BOUGHT. RIGHT ONCE AGAIN SEE IF
THERE'S ANY WITNESSES ON THE
TELEPHONE. BEFORE I TAKE A
MOTION. TO THE RIGHT- SO ARE
THE MOTION SHOULD BE TO. THE
MOTION AS AMENDED. TO A PROBES.
THE MOTION OKAY SO SENATOR ONE
WIENER HAS NOW MADE THAT MOTION
AGAIN SEEING NO QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS IN THE DíAS YOU CAN
CALL THE ROLL. TO PASS AS
AMENDED SKINNER BY IN OUR AYE
MORLOCK. BRADFORD BRADFORD AYE
JACKSON AYE JACKSON AYE
MITCHELL MITCHELL AYE MORALE.
WIENER WIENER AYE. FIVE TWO TWO
FIVE ZERO IN ORDER TO LOWER
YOUR BILL APPROVED. FIVE ZERO
AND THANK YOU WE WILL NOW MOVE
ON TO OUR NEXT AUTHOR AND NEXT
BILL WHICH IS SB NINE FOURTEEN
SENATOR PORTANTINO. REPUBLICANS
STORY ALL RE OPEN THE ROLE. I
DIDN'T CLOSES. GREAT CENTER
PORTANTINO MORNING- MADAM CHAIR
AND COLLEAGUES TODAY I AM
PRESENTING SB NINE FOURTEEN
QUATTRO ACQUIRE THE DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE TO VERIFY THE
VALIDITY OF A HUNTING LICENSE
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND
WILDLIFE WHEN A PERSON UNDER
THE AGE OF TWENTY ONE IT USES A
LICENSE TO PURCHASE. FIRE ARE.
AND AS YOU KNOW THE TRAGEDY IN
POWER WAY OCCURRED BECAUSE- THE
SHOOTER WAS ABLE TO OBTAIN A
LONG GUN WITH AN INVALID
HUNTING LICENSE AND AT THIS
BEEN IN PLACE THERE WOULD HAVE
BEEN A CHECK ON THAT LICENSE
AND THE SUGAR WOULD HAVE BEEN
TO DIVIDE THE PURCHASE AND SO.
WE CAN'T- SAVE THAT WERE LOS
THERE BUT WE CERTAINLY CAN DO
OUR BEST TO PREVENT A TRAGEDY
IN THE FUTURE- THIS BILL ALSO
CLEANS UP SOME CODE SECTIONS
AND CROSS REFERENCING. THE
SUGGESTION OF THE PART JUSTICE.
UNDER CURRENT TRANSFERRING A
PURCHASE A FIREARM- WITHOUT A
LIGHT THERE'S A VERY QUE
PROCESS TO TEND TO THE SERVER
MAKE SURE THAT THAT HAPPENED.
FOR THESE REASONS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK PRIVATE. THANK
YOU I THINK WE HAVE A- Q. WE
HONESTLY FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE SHOULD BE ONLINE YES WE
HAVE ACTUALLY ARE YOURS FROM
THE BERMAN JUSTICE ON THE HOST
LINE. AND A MODERATOR YOU CAN
OPEN THE HOSE LINE FOR DESIRES
AND YOU HAVE THREE MINUTES. THE
MORNING THANK YOU CENTER IN
THIS AMBASSADORS WITH THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE PLEASED TO SUPPORT
SECTION EIGHT TEN AND ELEVEN ON
BEHALF OF THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
BUT THERE I'D LIKE TO THANK
SENATOR PORTANTINO. LEADING THE
FACTION AND AT THE NINE ONE. HE
IS HERE AND ACTUALLY EIGHT
REGARDING CODE SECTION TWO
EIGHT TWO THREE ZERO ARE ISSUES
THAT WERE TENNIS MANY BY THE
NATIONAL RIFLE ASSOCIATION LAST
YEAR. IF YOU DON'T ACTION PAN
YOU KNOW PROTECTION THREE ZERO
THREE SEVEN ZERO OUR ISSUES IN
THE STATUTE GOVERNING
BACKGROUND CHECKS FOR ANY
NATION PURCHASE. AND THE ISSUES
AND- LEVIN. YOUR CONNECTION
THREE ZERO FOUR SEVEN ZERO ARE
ISSUES ARISING FROM EIGHTY
EIGHT I MEAN NINE FROM LAST
YEAR REGARDING. YOUR PART.
SECTION EIGHT ARE MINOR CLEANUP
CHANGE MINOR CLEAN UP
PROVISIONAL LEADING OBSOLETE
SECTION OF THE CODE. AND ACTION
HAND LEVIN OUR CULTURE YOU
THINK CORRECTION UPDATING THE
CHEMICAL TO REFLECT CHANGES
MADE LAST YEAR. WE WERE ASK FOR
YOUR AYE LOW. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU I'M NOW LET'S SEE IF THERE
ARE ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT. OUR FIRST IN THIS-
HEARING ROOM. FOR TWO OR THREE
ARE THERE ANY. THIRTEEN NINE
LET'S SEE IF THERE'S ANY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT IN THE
OTHER HEARING ROOM. WHILE I
LOOK SEVENTY FIRST SO THERE'S
NO ONE THERE EITHER MODERATOR
WE HAVE ANYONE ON THE PHONE WHO
WANTS TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. IF
YOU WISH TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
IT'S ONE THEM ZERO ON YOUR
PHONE. AND NON CARING UP ON THE
PHONE PLEASE CONTINUE. ALL
RIGHT SO WITH- WILL NOW HEAR
FROM ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. I DON'T HAVE ANY
LISTED AS FORMAL OPPOSITION SO
BUT FIRST LET'S SEE IF THERE'S
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
HEARING ROOM FOR TWO OR THREE.
SEEING NINE UNLESS SOMEONE
QUICKLY RAN INTO THE OTHER
HEARING ROOM I WOULD SAY THAT
THERE'S NONE THERE EITHER BUT
YOU CAN CHECK QUICKLY. ALL
RIGHT- SINCE THERE ARE NONE IN
THE OTHER HEARING ROOM ARE
THERE ANY ON THE PHONE WHO WANT
TO. TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION. HI
IN OPPOSITION ON THE PHONE IT'S
ONE THEN ZERO. GOING UP ON THE
PHONE LINES. EXCELLENT WAITER
FIFTEEN SECONDS TO SEE IF THERE
IS ANYONE ELSE WHO A BABY IS
STILL TRYING TO FIGURE OUT THE
PHONE LINE. MODERATE BY CHECK.
THIS IS THE ONE IF THEIR
OPPOSITION. SEVEN NINE ON THE
LINE MODERATOR. NO NOBODY ON
THE PHONE LINES QUEUING UP AT
THIS TIME EXCELLENT RIGHT
MEMBERS DO YOU HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS FOR- SENATOR
PORTANTINO. YEAH BURGER MOTION
BUT I THINK SENATOR MORE LIKE
YOU HAVE A QUESTION O AHEAD
I'M JUST CURIOUS IF THERE'S AN
EXPLANATION ON THE FEE ISSUE
THAT'S INVOLVED WITH THIS BILL.
THAT WAS PART OF THE- CHAPTER
IN OUT ISSUES WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE- WE'RE
JUST MAKING IT SAID CODE
SECTION ISSUE SO MAYBE SHE CAN
ANSWER THAT QUESTION. WE'RE NOT
DOING AWAY WITH THE FEES IT'S
MY UNDERSTANDING E'RE JUST
CLARIFYING THE LANGUAGE OTHERS
CHAP TECHNICAL CHAP DURING IT.
SHE'S ON THE LINE SHE CAN
PROBABLY ANSWER THAT IT IS MY
UNDERSTANDING WAS NEITHER A
INCREASE OR- DECREASE IT WAS AS
JUST DESCRIBED DAY AND-
SOMETIMES OUR CODES GETTING
CONFLICT INADVERTENTLY. BUT
ACTUALLY HIRES IS THERE ANY.
ANY FURTHER CLARIFICATION YOU
WANNA MAKE THAT SHE WOULD BE ON
THE HOST LINE MODERATOR. THANK
YOU SENATOR I'M NOT SURE IF THE
QUESTION IS REGARD AND SHOOT IN
REGARDS TO IT TWO EIGHT TWO
THREE- OR ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
INSPECTIONS TEN OR SECTION
ELEVEN. THE SECOND TEN AND
ELEVEN YEAH ACOSTA CHANGE SO IT
JUST REFLECTS AT. OFFERING YOU
CAN THREE OH AND. OBSOLETE
PROVISION REQUIRE. AS AN ISSUE
THAT WITH BY THE RIGHT
ASSOCIATION YEAR. THERE'S
NOTHING BEING ADDED. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR FIVE SO ANY OTHERS
QUESTIONS. ALL RIGHT AND THIS
THIS BILL WE THE DOES THE
MOTION I THINK IT ALREADY HAD
THE AMENDMENTS RIGHT WE RIGHT
HERE OKAY YOUR STAFF ACROSS THE
AMENDMENTS WHICH THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WORKING WITH MY STE. YEAH
IT TO WHERE IT IS TODAY. YOU'RE
WELCOME CENTER PORTANTINO
ALRIGHT SO WE HAVE A MOTION
BEFORE US. IN IT IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS- LET'S HAVE A
ROLL CALL. SB NINE FOURTEEN DO
PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS
SKINNER BY IN OUR AYE MORLOCK.
BRADFORD BRADFORD I'D JACKSON
HI JACKSON I'D MITCHELL AYE
MITCHELL AYE MORALE. MORRELL
NOW WIENER WIENER I'D- SIX ONE.
THE BILL IS OUT SIX ONE CENTER
FORTY FIVE OH FIVE ONE SORRY-
UNANIMOUS CAN. ANYWAY BILLS OUT
FIVE ONE THANK YOU SENATOR
PORTANTINO WILL NOW MOVED TO-
SB NINE SEVEN NINE SENATOR
JONES. YOU MAY PROCEED. GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR- WE ARE I
THINK IN THE PROCESS OF GETTING
MY WITNESS ON THE PHONE RIGHT
NOW TOO SO. HOPEFULLY BY THE
TIME I GET DONE REMARKS WILL
HAVE THAT DONE. GOOD MORNING I
AM PRESENTING SB NINE SEVEN
NINE SENATE BILL NINETY NINE
MAKES A- MAKES IT A CRIME TO
ENTER THE CURTILAGE OF A
RESIDENTIAL HOME. WITH THE
INTENT TO STEAL A SHIP
PACKAGING CARTILAGES A NEW
WORD. THAT I LEARNED THIS YEAR
AS A RESULT OF THIS. ARE ISSUE
OF I COULD USE BEING STOLEN OFF
OF PEOPLE'S PORCHES IS A STATE
WIDE AND- I LEARNED IT NATIONAL
ISSUE AS SOME LIMóN LOW IS
ALSO WORKING ON A SIMILAR BILL.
IN 20001810% OF ALL RETAIL
SALES IN THE COUNTRY OCCURRED
ON LINE. BECAUSE OF THE COVERT
NINETEEN SITUATION ONLINE SALES
HAVE INCREASED EXPONENTIALLY.
IN FACT BETWEEN MARCH AND APRIL
OF THIS YEAR ONLINE SALES
INCREASED 49% IN THE COUNTRY.
BOB SHOPPING ONLINE CAN BE
EASIER AND SAFER UNFORTUNATELY
THIEVES WITH MEL INTENT. ARE
INCREASINGLY STEALING PACKAGES
ANY SENIOR THIEVES HAVE OFTEN
BEEN REFERRED TO IN THE MEDIA
AS PORCH PIRATES. THE
DISPROPORTIONATE AMOUNT OF
PORTS PIRACY OCCURS IN
CALIFORNIA IN 20001930% OF ALL
STOLEN PACKAGES ACROSS THE
NATION WERE STOLEN IN THIS
STATE. THESE PACKAGES CONTAIN A
WIDE VARIETY OF ESSENTIAL ITEMS
SUCH AS MEDICATIONS AND FOOD.
ANY SENIORS AND DISABLED
INDIVIDUALS RELY ON PACKAGE
DELIVERY FOR SURVIVAL. IN ORDER
PROTECT THOSE MOST VULNERABLE
WE MUST TAKE EVERY STEP WE CAN
TODAY TO STOP PORCH PRIVACY. IS
A BIPARTISAN BILL SEC ALLEN IS
THERE IS A CO AUTHOR OF THIS
BILL AND AS I MENTIONED A
SIMILAR LOW ALLEN IS A CO
AUTHOR. AND ASSEMBLYMAN LOW
WORKING ON A BIT I IN THE
ASSEMBLY. THE NEW ME AT HOME.
WELL MAYBE I'LL STRIKE THAT
FROM MY CAR THEN. JOHN
DIMENSION. THIS IS A WIDE RANGE
OF OPTIONS WHEN REPORTS PRIVATE
STILL THREE PACKAGES WITHIN A
THREE YEAR PERIOD I WAS REALLY
SURPRISED WHEN I INTRODUCED
THIS BILL- BACK IN THE FALL HOW
MUCH MEDIA. GEN WAS GIVEN TO
THIS TOPIC I DID RADIO
INTERVIEWS ACROSS THE STATE
AND- I'M AT LEAST EIGHT OR NINE
INTERVIEWS IN DIFFERENT AREAS
OF CALIFORNIA AND THEN EVEN
OTHER STATES THAT REACHED OUT
TO US TO KIND OF FIGURE OUT.
YOU KNOW THREE AND I THINK WE
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO KIND OF
TAKE A LEADERSHIP ROLE HERE AS
AS WE LIKE TO DO HERE IN
CALIFORNIA IN THE SENATE IN THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE AND
REALLY SET THE EXAMPLE FOR THE
REST OF THE COUNTRY. THAT'S IT
FOR MY OPENING COMMENTS I DO
BELIEVE. SAN DIEGO DISTRICT
ATTORNEY SUMMER STEPHAN. IS ON
THE PHONE SHE'S MY MAIN WITNESS
SO IF SHE CAN. SHARE HER
THOUGHTS AND SHE'S AVAILABLE
FOR QUESTIONS ALSO. BEST
MODERATOR YOU CAN OPEN THE HOST
LINE FOR. A D. A. STEPHAN WHO
IS THE MAIN WITNESS AND WILL
HAVE THREE MINUTES. LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE PROCEED. THANK YOU
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS- I AM SUMMER
STETSON SAN DIEGO COUNTY IS
DISTRICT ATTORNEY SAN DIEGO
COUNTY IS THE SECOND LARGEST
COUNTY IN OUR STATE BUT ALONG
WITH ALMOST EVERY. IN OUR STATE
TO WE ARE SUFFERING FROM THIS
PORCH PIRACY IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT TO DISTINGUISH THE
SECOND CHANCES AND THIRD
CHANCES THAT WE GIVE FOR LOW
LEVEL OFFENSES. SHOULD FORGE
BUYER IS NOT THAT KIND OF CRIME
IT IS AN ORGANIZED CRIME IT'S
NOT THE KIND OF CROP SOMEBODY
GOES INTO A STORE AND THEY'RE
HUNGRY OR DATE IT'S AS SOME
ITEM DIAPERS SOMETHING ELSE
AND- THEY TAKE IT TO WHICH I
CONDONE BUT IS A DIFFERENT
CATEGORY THAN PEOPLE. WHO ARE
ORGANIZED AROUND. BACK AND FIVE
WE KNOW FROM OUR AND- THAT THEY
FOLLOW THE TRUCKS BE COLD AND
ESSENTIALLY PREY ON PEOPLE
WAITING FOR VERY IMPORTANT
ITEMS DURING THE SCHOOL BUT
NINETEEN HERE YOU HAD MORE AND
MORE PEOPLE ARE REAL LONG AND-
DELIVERIES SENIORS ARE WAITING
FOR A MEDICATION PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES. CAN LEAVE THEIR
HOME OR- YOUR NO DEFICIENCIES
ARE WAITING FOR THOSE PACKAGES
AND THESE PACKAGES THAT ARE
ESSENTIAL TO THEM THEY MAY
CONTAIN TWENTY DOLLARS WORTH OR
HUNDREDS OF DOLLARS BUT WE
WOULDN'T KNOW ALL AND NEITHER
DOES THE PORCH. STATE JUST WAIT
FOR THAT APPROACH AND IT IS
THEIR BUSINESS TO TAKE PEOPLES-
ITEMS THAT THEY NEED. AT THE
BILL IS A VERY MODEST BILL
ADDED BALLOT IS ESSENTIAL AND
PRESS THE WAY THAT IT DOES THAT
IS IT THE SHOULD ORDINARY THAT
FROM THESE PORCH BY. IT TO MEAN
THAT YOU ACTUALLY TO ENTER INTO
THE VILLAGE. SOMEONE HOME PRIME.
THERE ARE A PART THERE IS
SAYING NO MATTER HOW STE OR
LARGE. IT IS YOUR HOME SOME ONE
BAGGAGE IS OUR LEFT HIM ONE IS
ENJOY ITS SENSUALLY YOUR HOME
ENVIRONMENT AND TAKING THIS
THING THAT YOU ABSOLUTELY NEED
AND THAT YOU ORDERED AND WITH
AN ECONOMIC DOWNTURN. MONEY AND
THINGS THAT PEOPLE PURCHASE
REALLY. ARE NEEDED BY THEM SO
BAD IS THE DISTINGUISHING
FACTOR AND- THIS BILL BY
SENATOR JONES I WANTED THANK
HIM DOES HE REASONABLE BALANCED
INCREASE THAT HOLD ACCOUNTABLE
THOSE WHO ARE ORGANIZED AND
HAVE DONE THIS OVER. WE THEY
GET CAUGHT WHICH IS THE DE
THING TO CATCH THEM IN THE
FIRST. PLACE THREE DIFFERENT
TIMES IT MEANS DONE AT A TENANT
BUT WE CANNOT THEM TO TIMES
THEN IT SO WHY BLUR THAT IS
FUNNY ASSEMBLY TO A KOMODO
BURGLARY WHERE YOU ENTER A
WALMART SOMETHING THAT IS NOT
AS INTRUSIVE ON HUMAN DIGNITY
ON WHAT PEOPLE CARE ABOUT- AND
ONE THAT TIME CANNOT BE MORE
URGENT RIGHT NOW IT SENDS. A
MESSAGE TO OUR COMMUNITY THAT
WE ARE ABOUT THE MEN WE
UNDERSTAND THEIR NEED TO
RECEIVE THESE PAGES AND TO BE
PROTECTED AND RESPECTED. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU- LET'S SEE I
KNOW  SENATOR JACKSON HAD A
QUESTION IS THAT TO YOU TO THE
AUTHOR THE MAIN WITNESS WE
STILL HAVE TO HEAR FROM
OPPOSITION AND FROM A PUBLIC
BUT WE CAN SO WOULD YOU LIKE TO
WAIT OKAY ALL RIGHT SO FIRST
LET'S SEE IF THERE ARE ANY
OTHER SUPPORTERS BOB. WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT OF THE- WHO WOULD AT
THIS POINT ONLY GIVE THEIR NAME
AND AFFILIATION WE'LL START
FIRST WITH ANY THOSE PRESENT IN
THIS ROOM HEARING ROOM FOR TWO
OR THREE. SEEING NINE OR THE
ANY PRESENT IN THE HEARING ROOM
AND ON THE SECOND FLOOR. RIGHT
SEEING NINE ARE THERE ANY
MODERATOR CAN YOU SEE IF THERE
ARE ANY WITNESSES WHO WANT TO
TEST FIND SUPPORT WERE ON THE
TELEPHONE. IT'S ONE AND ZERO TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THE PHONE
LINE. THERE IS ONE. NO THERE
ARE NINE OKAY SO NOW LET US
TURN TO THE OPPOSITION AND-
THERE ARE TWO FORMAL OPPOSITION
ON THE HOST LINE IN IN TOTAL
THEY WILL HAVE THREE MINUTES
JUST AS THE SUPPORT DID- SO
MODERATOR TO DO OPEN THE HOST
LINE FOR DEREK MORGAN AND MIKE
A DOCTOR OFF GO AHEAD. DEREK
MORGAN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK
YOU. ALL MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE GOOD MORNING. THIS
KIND OF BILLS NINE SEVEN NINE.
INSPECTOR THE WORK DONE BY THE
COMMITTEE TO ADDRESS AND USE
THE PACKAGE TO ACT. LIKE THAT
RESULT FROM SOCIAL DUTIES AND
INCOME INEQUALITY. BILL IS THE
LONG POLICY FOR THE MOMENT. SB
NINE SEVEN NINE SIX TO CREATE A
NEW CRIMINALITY PUNISHABLE BY
UP TO A YEAR IN JAIL FOR MERELY
ENTERING AN AREA THAT IN A
NEIGHBORHOOD IT'S HARD TO
BALLOT OR DESPITE. THIS BILL
ALSO GIVES NO GUIDANCE AS TO
HOW TO BE IMPLEMENTED FRANKLY
WITHOUT ACTUATING PROFILING.
ESPECIALLY WHEN ARMS
NEIGHBORHOOD WATCHMAN AND A
LIGHT. SHOULD TAKE IT UPON
THEMSELVES TO ENFORCE THE LAW.
FURTHER THIS BILL LACKS CLARITY
ON HOW TO DISTINGUISH THE
INTENT TO STEAL A PACKAGE AT
THE BEHAVIOR SO THAT. APART
FROM MERELY TAKING A WALK WE'RE
GOING FOR A RUN. PERHAPS
ELECTION YOUR CAMPUS DURING
WORK ANY OTHER ACTIVITY. THIS
BILL IS RIGHT FOR PROVIDING
ABUSE ESPECIALLY NOW WITH THE
CALLING ON ESSENTIAL WORKERS TO
GO INTO NEIGHBORHOODS ARE NOT
FAMILIAR WITH. ALL SUPPLY AND
CONNECTED. DESPITE THE WORK OF
ADVOCATES AND THIS BODY TO
ADDRESS EXPLICIT AND IMPLICIT
BIAS THIS BILL INSTEAD SIGNAL
THAT WE SHOULD LOOK TO EACH
OTHER WITH SUSPICION. RUNNING
pIN WAYS WORSE THAN BLOOMING
BUYERS. SENATORS THE PUBLIC
SAFETY COMMITTEE ON BEHALF OF
OUR BIGGER CENTER FOR HUMAN
RIGHTS I URGE YOUR NOTE. THE
NEXT KEY WITNESS MODERATOR ON
THE PHONE FIRST LINE. LIKE A
DOCTOR OFF YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MIGHT GET DOCTOR ALSO
ON BEHALF OF THE ACLU OF
CALIFORNIA WE APPRECIATE THE
AUTHOR'S EFFORTS AND THE
EFFORTS OF THE COMMITTEE AND
COMMITTEE STAFF NARROW THE
SCOPE OF THE BILL UNFORTUNATELY
THIS DOES NOT REMOVE OUR
OPPOSITION. FIRST WE DO NOT
BELIEVE THIS. THE FERRY UNDER
EXISTING LAW A PERSON CAN
ALREADY BE PROSECUTED FOR
ENTERING THE CARTILAGE AT HOME
WITH THE INTENT TO COMMIT AND
FAST. AND CONVICTED OF A
VARIETY OF CRIMES INCLUDING
ATTEMPTED PASSED ATTEMPTED
RECEIVING STOLEN PROPERTY AND
ATTEMPTED MAIL FAST AMONG OTHER
OFFENSES. GIVEN THE
AVAILABILITY OF EXISTING LAWS
WE DO NOT BELIEVE SEPARATE
CRIME AND- VERY. AND. CREATING
THE PUNISH FOR THIS WILL NOT
PEOPLE FROM ENGAGING IN THE
PRESCRIBED CONTACT THE RESEARCH
IT'S CLEAR THAT THE FACT OF
PUNISHMENT RATHER THAN A LINK
THERE CENTER AND IS A LOT MAY
SERVE AS A DETERRENT INCREASING
JAIL SENTENCE AT THIS TIME
CA ONLY STARTS TO MAKE OUR
CON COUNTY JAIL TO MORE
DANGEROUS DURING ON CRAFT THEM
TO THE PUBLIC CRY STASHED. MY
COLLEAGUES SAID WE ARE. THAT SB
NINE SEVEN NINE COULD BE YOU AS
A TOOL TO DISCRIMINATE AGAINST
HOMELESS PEOPLE PEOPLE WITH
MENTAL ILLNESS AND PEOPLE OF
COLOR IN PARTICULAR WE FELLER
FEAR THAT THE BILL COULD BE
USED AS A PRETEXT FOR ARRESTING
PEOPLE AGAINST TO LAW
ENFORCEMENT OR PROPERTY OWNERS
ARE EXPLICITLY IMPLICITLY BY
ASKING. PEOPLE WHO THEY
BELIEVED TO NOT ALONG. FOR ALL
OF THESE REASONS WHERE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED TO THE
BALLOT URGENT. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU LET US SEE IF THERE'S ANY
OTHER WITNESSES- IN OPPOSITION
TO THE BILL AGAIN THIS IS YOUR
NAME AFFILIATION AND YUROK
OPPOSITION ONLY AT THIS POINT.
LET'S SEE IF THERE'S ANYONE
HERE IN THIS HEARING ROOM.
SEEING NINE ARE THERE IS THERE
ANYONE IN THE HEARING ROOM ON
THE SECOND FLOOR SEEING NINE-
MODERATOR. BY YOU CAN SEE IF
THERE'S ANYONE ON THE LINE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION. FOR THOSE ON THE
PHONE LINES IF YOU'D LIKE TO
HAVE YOUR VOICE HEARD PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME ONE MOMENT PLEASE. AND WE
DO NOT HAVE ANYBODY CURING UP
ON THE PHONE LINES AT THIS TIME
PLEASE CONTINUE. THE. A
PROVINCIAL. UPON THANK YOU SO
BUT SEEING THAT THERE ARE NO
OTHER WITNESSES. EITHER IN THE
HEARING ROOM OR ON THE PHONE SO
I WILL ALLOW SENATOR JACKSON TO
ASK YOUR QUESTION THAT I
BELIEVE CENTER MITCHELL YOU ADD
A COMMENT OR QUESTION
ADDITIONALLY ALRIGHT LET IT AND
EIGHT CENTER MORE LIKE WELL SO
WE'RE GOING. THANK YOU THANK
YOU MANAGE- AND CENTER BROWN-
MY EARLIER OBSERVATION THAT
WHEN WE ARE SUPPOSED TO DEAL
WITH EACH BUILT ON ITS OWN
MERITS IRRESPECTIVE OF WHAT
OTHER BILLS ARE BEING PRESENTED
THAT'S NOT BEFORE US TODAY SO
THAT WAS THE REASON FOR MY
OBSERVATION UP. AND THEN I
THINK YOU STILL HAVE YOUR KEY
WITNESS THE DISTRICT ATTORNEY
OF SAN DIEGO ON THE LINE SO
EITHER CENTER IF YOU WOULD
ANSWER THIS HER HAVE HER DO
THAT. BOB WE HAVE THE PRIME
PETTY THEFT THE CHARITY ON THE
BOOKS WHAT DISTINGUISHES THIS.
OF NEW CRIME FROM THE CRIME OF
PETTY THEFT THE PENALTY IS I
UNDERSTAND THAT IS SUPPOSED TO
BE THE SAME THAT THE WOBBLY
PROVISION HAS BEEN REMOVED SO
THIS IS A MISDEMEANOR IN FACT
PETTY THEFT WITH THE PRIOR. I
THINK IT'S STILL A FELONY. WHY
SHOULD WE BE CREATING A NEW
MEASURE THAT IS. LESS
ULTIMATELY- AS IF WE CAN'T
TERMS OF AND FOR THE CRIME OF
PETTY THEFT- AND HOW IS THIS.
HOW DOES THIS FROM THE
PERSPECTIVE OF PROSECUTOR
CREATE IT AN EASIER MECHANISM-
TO- TO PROSECUTE INTO
ULTIMATELY FIND A- A BIRD THE
ALLEGED PERPETRATOR GUILTY OF
THE CRIME- WHEN YOU HAVE THE
CRIME OF PETTY THEFT. THE BOOK.
AT REALLY GOOD QUESTION IF I
CAN I WOULD I WOULD LOVE. A
STEP TO ADDRESS THAT THANK YOU
MODERATOR YOU CAN HAVE THE HOSE
LINE FOR DA STUFF INTO A ANSWER
CENTER JACKSON'S QUESTION. ONE
MOMENT PLEASE. THE LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
THANK YOU SENATOR FOR THAT
QUESTION IT IS MY
UNDERSTANDING- AS OF A FEW
MOMENTS BEFORE THE HEARING
BEGAN AT THAT THE- AMENDMENT TO
WASN'T TAKEN AND THAT WHAT THIS
SECTION DOES DIFFERENT IS ON AT
THE- OF AND THIS WOULD MAKE IT.
BOB BLUR PUNISHABLE BY A
MISDEMEANOR OR BY- LOCAL JAILED
ELEVEN SEVENTY SENTENCE OF FIVE
SIXTEEN MONTHS TWO OR THREE
YEARS AND LOCAL JAIL NOT A
STATE PRISON. AND SO THIS BILL
AS OPPOSED TO THE PAST- DOES
HAVE A GRADUATED CONSEQUENCE SO
THAT FOR THE ORGANIZED PORCH
PETER THAT ARE INTRUDING ON
PEOPLE'S- PLAYS AT. THEIR WELL
BEING AND MY MIND- THAT THERE
IS A GRADUATED CONSEQUENCE- THE-
YEAH THE OTHER THAT PROP. FOR
SEVEN. WE MORE AT THE AT BILL
TO HAVE GRADUATED CONSEQUENCES
FOR PETTY THEFT SO THIRTY
PASSED THE FIRST TIME OR THE
HUNDREDTH TIME IN ANY GIVEN
YEAR WOULD STILL BE A
MISDEMEANOR- AND WOULD NOT EVER
GRADUATE TO A FELONYMATTER HOW
MANY TIMES. ONE OF THE- THIS
BILL DOES IS IT TRACKING NICE
IS THE IMPACT OF PORCH PIRACY
ON AND I THINK IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT TO KNOW WHAT IT EIGHT
PROBABLY AFFECTS PEOPLE OF
COLOR AND OFF LOWER ECONOMIC
STATUS THAN IT WOULD DO THE
WEALTHY WHO CAN ORDER AND RE
ORDER THEIR PACKAGES AND SO
THOSE ARE THE PEOPLE MOST
AFFECTED. MAY I GET
CLARIFICATION MADAM THOUGHT MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT THE
AUTHOR DID IN FACT REMOVE THE
WATER BLUR SO IS THAT ACCURATE
YES CORRECT THE THOSE
AMENDMENTS ARE BEING OFFERED
TODAY IN A AND I'M WILLING TO
ACCEPT THEM OF THAT. HELLO THE-
TWO GET POSITION OF MOVING THE
BILL FOR. WELCOME MAT. THAT IF
THAT'S THE CASE THEN THIS BILL
DOESN'T DO ANYTHING MORE THAN A
PETTY THEFT WOULD DO BECAUSE IF
YOU'RE CONVICTED OF THIS ONE
TIME OR FIFTY TIMES IT'S STILL
A MISDEMEANOR- AND SO I. WHAT'S
AT THE PENALTY IS THE PENALTY
WILL BE THE SAME IS THE- AS I
UNDERSTAND IT MAY I MASS FOR
CLARIFICATION THAT MADAM CHAIR
WILL THE PENALTY BE THE SAME.
AS IF THIS WERE INDEED A PETTY
THEFT. I BELIEVE SOBRE OUTSIDE
I RETURNED TO MY COMMITTEE
CONSULTANT TO SEE IF. I CAN GET
A CLARIFICATION ON THAT.
THERMOS KENNEDY. THE BUT THE
WEATHER THE PENALTY IS GOING TO
BE THE SAME I THINK THAT- YOU
KNOW LET ME CONFIRM WITH STELLA
BUT THEY I BELIEVE THAT-
THEY'RE SIMILAR OFFENSES THE
DIFFERENCE HERE IS THERE'S
DIFFERENT PROOF ELEMENTS SO THE
PENALTIES WILL BE SIMILAR BUT
HERE YOU'RE GONNA HAVE TO PROVE
THE INTENT TO STEAL RIGHT AND
THAT WAS MY NEXT QUESTION
HAVING. BEEN A PROSECUTOR. LONG
TIME AGO NONETHELESS I REMEMBER
THAT SPECIFIC CONTENT CRIMES
ARE HARDER TO PROVE IN GENERAL
INTENT CRIMES IN GENERAL INTENT
CRIME AT YOUR SHOW THAT THE ACT
WAS DONE THAT'S THE END OF IT
YOU DON'T HAVE TO GO ON. AND OF
THE- OF THE PERPETRATOR. AND
THAT IS THE SORT OF IT HOW DO
WE PROVE INTENT AS I UNDERSTAND
IT THIS. THIS BILL TALKS ABOUT
INTENT RIGHT- BUT WHAT DOES
THAT MEAN ATTENTION OF THE
POSSESSION OF A OF A BOX CUTTER
OR OTHER PACKAGES AND I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY. DISAGREE WITH THE
NOTION THAT RICH PEOPLE CAN GO
OUT AND READ BY THINGS I THINK
THAT IF THE STAFF- AND I THINK
THAT WE HAVE TO RESPECT THAT.
THE VICTIMS OF THAT THE F. BUT
I CHEST I'M HAVING TROUBLE
SEEING WHY WE NEED TO ADD THIS
PARTICULAR. OFFENSE WHEN WE
ALREADY A PETTY THEFT AND WE
ALREADY HAVE THE ABILITY TO
CONNECT WITH THE SAME
PUNISHMENT THAT THAT NOW THIS
WOULD MOVE FORWARD I THINK YOU
ON A KEY TOPIC THERE THE
INTENT. AND THEN I ALSO
APPRECIATE YOUR CALM. IN A
RECORDING EIGHT OF THE VICTIMS
I WAS SURPRISED IN IN STE THE
RADIO BUT I DID THIS IS. TENS
THERE'S- ONE OF THE COMMENTS
FOR LISTENERS I. AM DON'T
REMEMBER WHAT MEDIA MARK WAS IN.
BUT WHAT IF THE PERSON TAKING
PACKAGE NEEDS AND THE PER IN
ORDER THE PACK. I LIKE I DON'T
I DON'T KNOW HOW TO ANSWER THAT
QUESTION YOU KNOW- BUT BACK TO
YOUR QUESTION ABOUT INTENT IN
IF SUMMER WANTS TO JUMP IN HERE
WITH A BETTER LOCATION. I'M
HAPPY TO DO THAT BECAUSE THAT
HAS COME UP A COUPLE TIMES AND-
AND I AND I APPRECIATE THAT IT
IS MORE DIFFICULT TO PROVE
CONTENT WE- DISCUSS THAT- WHEN
WE ARE. INTRODUCING THE KEY
TRACK. I THINK CURTILAGE. AND
THEN. FENCE AND SO YOU'VE GOT.
AND THEN AS SUMMER- ALLUDED TO
THE ORGANIZATION. ASPECT OF
THIS WHEN YOU PUT ALL THOSE
TOGETHER. I THINK THAT'S WHEN
THE AND I'M NOT I'M NOTBEEN A
PROSECUTOR- NOR. FORTUNATELY
EVER PROSECUTED SO I AVEN'T
LIVED THAT EXPERIENCE- I DON'T
THINK THEY GO HAND IN HAND. SO
I THINK YOU KNOW IT'S UP TO THE
PROSECUTOR IN LAW OBVIOUSLY LAW
ENFORCEMENT TO PUT THOSE THINGS
TOGETHER I THINK THAT ALSO
ADDRESSES. TURNS AT THE WITH.
OUR OF. APPROACH IN IN AND AT.
YOU KNOW ALL THOSE OTHER THINGS
AS WELL THAT. THIS IS ALREADY A
HARD THING TO PROVE. AND SO
YOU'RE HAVING TO HAVE- A
PERSON. OFFENDED ME MULTIPLE
TIMES FOR THIS TO COME INTO
FACT BECAUSE THEY HAVE TO ENTER
THE CURTILAGE WHICH IS A
DEFINED. AS DIFFERENT FREE TO-
DOMICILE BECAUSE HE DOMICILED.
THIRTY I JUST LEARNED THIS I
SAW LIKE EXPERT I'M REALLY NOT
BUT YOU KNOW FOR A SINGLE
FAMILY HOME THE CURTILAGE BEGAN
BEGINS WITH YOU CROSS OFF THE
PUBLIC SIDEWALK UNDER THE
PERSONAL PROPERTY AND AN
APARTMENT IT'S DIFFERENT IT'S
AT THE DOOR YOU KNOW THE NOT
ALWAYS OF THE BUILDING AND
YOU'RE NOT IN THE CURRENT. AGE
OF THAT HOME- SO. I THINK WHEN
YOU PUT ALL THOSE THINGS
TOGETHER AND THEN OTHER ASPECTS
OF THE- CASE INDIVIDUAL CASES I
THINK IS WHEN YOU ARE ABLE TO
DEVELOP INTENT. THE PROBLEM IS
IF I'M IN AND OUT OF THE FOR
THE NEXT. QUESTION THE PROBLEM
IS IT'S STILL PETTY THEFT
WHETHER THEY'RE IN YOUR
CURTILAGE OR NOT AND I IT JUST
SEEMS TO ME WHILE RECOGNIZING
THAT THESE KINDS OF PETTY
THEFTS ARE OCCURRING. MORE AND
MORE FREQUENTLY- AND-
APPALLINGLY SELF FOR A VARIETY
OF REASONS- IT SEEMS THAT WE
HAVE THE ABILITY NAY. TO
PROSECUTE AND PERHAPS THE
QUESTION TO THE TO THE DISTRICT
ATTORNEY IF I MAY IS. WHY IS IT
OUR PERSPECTIVE IS A PROSECUTOR
WHY DO YOU BELIEVE THAT GIVEN
THE FACT THAT THE- DEFENSE IS
GOING TO BE MISTER. THIRTY
WOULD THAT YOU WOULD CHARGE
THIS IS LIEU OF A PETTY THEFT
CHARGE IF YOU WERE GOING TO GO
AHEAD AND PROSECUTE SOMEONE WHO
WAS ACCUSED OF COMMITTING. THE
OFFENSE. MODERATOR WILL ALLOW-
DA CHEF AND TO ANSWER. THANK
YOU SENATOR AND I APPRECIATE
YOUR EXPERTISE AND BACKGROUND
IN THIS- THIS PARTICULAR-
SENATE BILL A PROPOSED SENATE
BILL MAKES THE PUNISHMENT A ONE
YEAR AS OPPOSED TO THAT ATTY
THAT. MAKES THE PUNISHMENT AS
SIX MONTHS PUNISHMENT IT ALSO
BRINGS IT INTO CONSISTENCY WITH
A COMMERCIAL BURGLARIES DOES
AND TRAINING LIKE A WALMART OR
A DIFFERENT PLACE WITH THAT
INTENT TO STEAL YOU STILL HAVE
TO SHOW WHY YOU WERE THERE BUT
YOU COULD LIVE AND SHOULD BE ON
THE FIRST AND- PRIOR HISTORY. I
TAKING OF FORTUNE. SO YOU KNOW
HOW TO WAIT TILL THEY COMPLETE
BUT AND POLICE CAN BE CALLED AN
ACTION CAN BE TAKEN JUST BY
VIEWING THAT THE PERSON IS ON
YOUR PROPERTY AND YOU KNOW IS A
PERSON YOU DON'T KNOW WHEN IS A
PERSON THAT. HAS THE TOOLS OR
THE THINGS OUR TRUCK WAITING
FOR THEM SO IF POLICE WERE TO
INVESTIGATE THEY'RE ABLE TO NOT
HAVE TO WAIT TILL THE PROJECT
CARRIES AWAY THE- ITEMS THAT
THEY STOLE AND ESPECIALLY WHEN
THEY PULL FROM A DOOR TO DOOR.
FOR ABLE TO STOP THEM BEFORE
GET THE BEST CAN OUR THIRD DOOR
SO THE FACT THAT THERE IS AN
EIGHT PLEASE. TO ONE YEAR
VERSION. AND AS A- OR YOU AT
THAT THE JOY WOULD HAVE THE
DISK AS WHAT WOULD THERE NO MAN
MINIMUM BEING. AND THE FACT
THAT IT LAWS FOR. THE GOOD
THAT'S NOT TO BE COMPLETED IN
THE PERSON TO GET AWAY AND THE
VEHICLE BUT TO HAVE- A PERSON
CALL ABOUT. SOMEONE TRYING TO
TAKE THEIR PACKAGES AND THEN
USE THAN NORMAL EVIDENCE THAT
WE HAVE FOR A VARIETY OF
INTENSE WE DO COMMERCIAL
BURGLARY OR POTENTIAL BURGLARY
IT ALL. TO SOMEBODY BE FOR THE
ABLE AND THEIR PRIOR INCIDENTS
AS EVIDENCE OF ANY. ARE ALL IT
WOULD ALLOW US TO CHARGE THAT
FULLER. AFTER IF THAT'S
SIMPLEST ROUTE TO GO YES
DEFINITELY WE IT WAS ONLY A ON-
ASKING FOR THE ANSWER TO THE
ONE QUESTION THAT CONNECTION I
GET CLARIFICATION YOU MENTION
AS I'VE GOT THREE OTHER MEMBERS
WHO WANT TO ASK QUESTIONS AND I
HAVE. A PHONE ON THE PHONE.
OKAY KLAY HERE VERSUS SIX
MONTHS AND THE ABILITY FOR A
LOT. IS THAT NOT NAY AVAIL IN
ANY THEFT. IT IS BUT YOU HAVE
TO ACTUALLY HAVE THAT THE PAST
MEANING YOU'VE TAKEN THAT
PACKAGE AND YOU ARE- YOU ARE
DONE YOU'VE STOLEN AS OPPOSED
TO SOMEBODY WHO IS- THE PERSON
WHO COMES BACK TO YOUR POOR AND
TAKES BACK **** THEY TAKE THEM.
THANKS ARMS LET ME BEFORE WE
ASK ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS JUST
BECAUSE WE NORMALLY HOWEVER
WITNESSES FIRST LET ME HAVE THE
MODERATE. FIVE THERE WERE TIMES
I BELIEVE THERE WERE SOME
WITNESSES WHO WANTED TO TEST
FIVE VIA THE PHONE LINES WHO
HAD TROUBLE QUEUING UP SO
MODERATOR CAN YOU TELL ME IF
THERE ARE ANY MRS WHO WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. YES
AND AS A REMINDER THAT WE DO
HAVE THREE IN QUEUE SO FAR IS A
WRITER IF YOU WISH TO QUEUE UP
AT THIS TIME YOUR PRESS ONE
EVENT ZERO. WE'LL GO TO LINE
NUMBER SIXTY SIX SIX SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN THIS IS ONLY YOUR
NAME A FILM XIN IF YOU'RE IN
SUPPORT OR NOT SUPPORT. GOOD
MORNING MR DANNECKER DARNELL ON
BEHALF OF THE CAMPAIGN TO THE
PUBLIC DEFENDER'S OFFICE IN
OPPOSITION. SORRY MODERATOR
WILL JUST LITTLE LINE NUMBER
THE JUST PROCEED. THANK YOU
WE'LL GO TO LINE NUMBER SIXTY
EIGHT SIX EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD MORNING. MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS YOU SHOWN MUCH
WE'RE ONBEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION AND THE COURT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU WILL
NOW GO TO LINE NUMBER FORTY
EIGHT FOUR EIGHT TWO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. LINE FORTY EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THE NEW HEARING
AUDIO WILL MOVE ALONG TO LINE
NUMBER TWENTY EIGHT TO EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I'M NOT SURE
HERNANDEZ ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ATTORNEYS FOR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE IN OPPOSITION.
MOVING ALONG TO LINE NUMBER
THIRTY THREE ZERO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS THE SURVIVING ALL
TOMORROW WITH CAPITAL ADVOCACY-
TRYING IN SUPPORT OF BEYOND HIS
JOB RETAILERS ASSOCIATION THANK
YOU. THE MODERATOR THANK YOU
WILL GO TO LINE NUMBER WILL GO
TO LINE NUMBER SIXTY TWO SIX
TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YEAH
THIS IS- MADDIE HYATT FROM THE
CALIFORNIA CIVIL LIBERTIES
ADVOCACY WE ARE ALSO IN STRONG
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU WILL GO
TO LINE NUMBER SEVENTY SEVEN
ZERO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I MEAN
THIS IS GREGORY FIDELITY
MACHINE JUSTICE IN STRONG
OPPOSITION URGING A NO VOTE
TODAY. THANK YOU AND THAT DOES
ACOSTA OUT OF TIME. ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU APPRECIATE THAT LET
US CONTINUE WITH THE QUESTIONS
FROM THE DíAS I BELIEVE THE
CITY CENTRE RITUAL LOTS OF
SENATOR MORE LOCKED IN SENATOR
BRADFORD AND THEN SENATOR
WIENER BUT THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR WE ARE SEEING AN AMAZING-
TRENDS NEW TRENDS AND ECONOMICS
IN TECHNOLOGY- ONE WE'RE SEEING
A LOT MORE SHIPPING IN THE
OTHERS WERE SINGING BRING.
PROVIDE WERE YOU ACTUALLY GET
TO SEE WHO'S AT YOUR PORCH.
ED'S VIDEOTAPED IN AND THEN IT
JUST. SEEMS TO BE SENT OUT
PUBLICLY BUT WE'RE EVEN SING IT
BY OUR AIRPORT WHEN I LANDED
THEY JUST BUILT UP WAREHOUSE IN
MONTHS TWO YEARS AGO. THE OTHER
TWO MORE WAREHOUSES. HELLO THIS
AREA ALONG. IT'S JUST A AN
AMAZING- SIGHT TO BEHOLD SO
THESE VIDEOS GET SENT TO THE-NEWS STATIONS AND SO WE GET TO
SEE SOMEONE WALKING RIGHT UP TO
THE PORCH AND THEN TAKING
SOMETHING AND THEN WALKING AWAY
AND IT IT'S- IT'S ALMOST
REPLACE CAR CHASES. THE NIGHTLY
NEWS SO I. FIND THIS REAL FAST
BECAUSE WHEN YOU BRING IT UP
PEOPLE REACT STAGES A MOSTLY
REACT TO LIKE. YEAH THIS IS
JUST NOT RIGHT THAT PEOPLE ARE
TAKING STUFF RIGHT OFF OF OUR-
PORCH IS IN FACT WE'RE SEEING
VIDEOS OF. PEOPLE FALLING
DELIVERY TRUCKS LIKE PRIME FED
EX UPS AND IT'S RIGHT THERE OFF
ON TV YOU CANNOT GOING THIS IS
INCREDIBLE. I'M SEEING YOU TO
DEALS ON. PUTTING IN GAG STUFF
INSIDE A BOX JUST TO HAVE
SOMEONE STILL WOULDN'T YOU KNOW
IT GETS SURPRISE WHEN IT'S
OPENED- EVEN WITH THE VIDEO IN
INSIDE TO SEE THEIR REACTION
OR- ARE WE'RE SEEING OBVIOUSLY
TRACKING DEVICES AS WELL THE-
TO CATCH THESE PEOPLE TOLD.
SOME OF THE MORE DISTURBING.
VIDEOS WE SEE ON TV IS WHEN
HOMEOWNER ACTUALLY CONFRONTS
THAT THE FRONT AND A COUPLE OF
THESE ARE NOT BEEN PRETTY. SO
I'M- CONCERNED I BROUGHT IT UP
YOU KNOW WHAT ONE OF MY
PRESCRIPTIONS ARE BY IN ALL
THESE CRITICAL. IS THAT PEOPLE
ARE CONCERNED ABOUT SO. CENTER
JONES I'M I'M REALLY GLAD YOU
BROUGHT SOMETHING FORWARDED IT
SHOWS THAT SACRAMENTO'S.
REACTIVE YOU KNOW WANTS TO DO
SOMETHING TO TRY TO ADDRESS-
THIS PARTICULAR SITUATION
BECAUSE I EIGHT AFTER WATCHING
THESE NEWS CLIP SIDE I HAVE
EVERYTHING FOR ME DELIVER TO MY
DISTRICTOFFICE. YOU KNOW GIVES
YOU DON'T PUT IT MY DOOR YOU
YOU ACTUALLY BRING IT BY SIGHT
DO THE SAFETY PURPOSE. GLAD SO
I JUST AND WHEN TIME IS RIGHT
MADAM CHAIRMAN MOVE THE BILL. A
BECAUSE I THINK. WE NEED TO
ADDRESS THE SITUATION SOME FORM
OR FASHION AND I THINK IT SHOWS
THAT SACRAMENTO'S AWARE AND IS
ADDRESSING. THE SITUATION SO
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR. ARTS CENTER BRADFORD
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND I TO-
ONE APPLE SOME CINNAMON SORT OF
BEEN STATED THERE'S NO DOUBT
WITH THE INCREASE OF HOME
DELIVERY- SERVICES THAT THERE
HAS BEEN AN INCREASE AND PORTS
PIRACY BUT A GREAT CONCERN TO
KEEP AN WITH. ADDING ADDITIONAL
I'M ARE ENHANCEMENT I THINK WE
KNOW THE HISTORY OF WHOSE
PRIMARILY IMPACTED BY ALL THESE
INCREASE CRIMES AND
ENHANCEMENTS AND I THINK WE
HAVE. BUT AT THE STATE YOU IN
WINNING CRIMES AND HAVE IT
DOESN'T THE TEAR CRIME IN ANY
SHE FORM OR FOR. BUT I THINK
WHAT REALLY GETS ME BECAUSE
pWE JUST WITNESSED AND GEORGIA.
OR YOU SAW A YOUNG AFRICAN
AMERICAN MAN JUST SIMPLY ENTER
ON UNOCCUPIED HOUSE. AND
RESIDENTS TO GET UPON
THEMSELVES TO BE JUDGE JURY AND
EXECUTIONER AND I'M FEARFUL
THAT THE EXPANSION OF THESE
CRIMES WILL ONLY EMPOWER THOSE
FOLKS WHO. ALREADY HAVE. BIASES
AS IT RELATES TO POOR MINORITY
PEOPLE SIMPLY BECAUSE THEY'RE
IN THE WRONG NEIGHBORHOOD SO- I
CAN'T SUPPORT THIS SITE TO
AGREE THAT LIKE I SAY THERE'S
AN INCREASE IN ON PORTS. AND
PIRACY BECAUSE OF AN EXPANSION
OF DELIVERY SERVICES BUT I JUST
THINK ON THE LAWS THAT ARE
CURRENTLY ON THE BOOK CLEARLY
ADDRESS THE CONCERNS ARE TRYING
TO ADDRESS. THANK YOU. SENATOR
WIENER. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
WHEN I FIRST SAW THIS BILL I
WAS INTRIGUED BY IT IS BECAUSE
THIS IS A VERY REAL ISSUE I
DON'T WANT TO. DOWNPLAY THAT IN
ANY WAY I KNOW JUST FOR THE
HOUR THIS IS BEEN GOING ON FOR
AWHILE BACK WHEN I WAS IN THE
WERE SUPERVISORS I GOT REGULAR.
DIFFERENT HORRIBLY PRESS
PACKAGE ARE WOULD BE STOLEN AND
THIS ISN'T ABOUT NOT HOLDING
PEOPLE ACCOUNTABLE PEOPLE WHO
STEAL SHOULD BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE AND- AND THE
CURRENT LAW DOES ALLOW FOR THAT
AND AS I READ THIS LAW THE MAIN
DIFFERENCE. WE GOT A CLEAR
FIVE. IS IT DOES INCREASE THE
PENALTY- AND FROM SIX MONTHS TO
SOLELY ONE YEAR ON I DON'T YOU
KNOW IT TOO. GO IN AND TRY TO
CLOSE LOOPHOLES TO MAKE SURE
PEOPLE. COMMIT CRIMES ARE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE WE WE'VE BEEN DOING
TRYING TO WORK AROUND AUTO
BURGLARIES- WELL. SUCCESSFULLY
THIRTY ONE PEOPLE ACCOUNTABLE
FOR THEIR BEHAVIOR- BUT
INCREASING THE PENALTY I DON'T.
DOES THE E. R. THE RIGHT PATH
HE SIX MY IS STILL BUT I THINK
PAY QUITE IMPACTFUL. SENTENCE
AND IF SOMEONE'S DOING IT
REPEATEDLY THOSE ARE SEPARATE
CRIMES EACH OF WHICH SUBJECT TO
SIX MONTHS SO I'M I'M NOT CALL
FOR PRESENT. BUFFY FIVE THE
BILL IS A THIS LEGISLATION
TODAY. SEVEN MITCHELL THANK YOU
VERY MUCH I JUST AGAIN I AGREE
WITH EVERY THE STATE WITH
EVERYONE HAS MADE THIS IS OF
CRIME OPPORTUNITY AND IT'S
UNFORTUNATE I TO STOP THE PROBE
SOLUTION ACTUAL CRIME YOU KNOW.
MY COLLEAGUES TALK ABOUT THAT
WE WILL. THIS BILL DOESN'T
APPLY TO BECAUSE THE VIDEO WE
SEE ARE ONCE. THIS ACTUALLY
STOLE AND ITEM. IT'S WHEN THEY
ACTUALLY TAKEN THE ITEM FROM
THE PORCH AT ARE LEAVING. MY
CHALLENGE WITH THE BILL- IT IS
IT'S MULTI FOLD YOU KNOW FIRST
OF ALL YOU KNOW THIS NOTION OF
YOU TO WRITE TO HIM BECAUSE OF
THE RING RING QUE. CARE MUST
ALSO. CAPTURE IMAGES OF PEOPLE
WALKING. ON THE PUBLIC SIDEWALK
AND SO THIS NOTION OF RIGHT TO
PRIVACY IS REALLY A TWO WAY
STREET I DON'T KNOW OF THE
EXTERIOR OF MY FRONT DOOR- AS
THE SUPPORTING WITNESS- PARK.
THE SAME. YEAH I. PERSONAL IT
TIED MY FRONT DOOR WITH REGARD
TO INTENT. WE HAVE HAD LOTS OF
CONVERSATIONS IN THIS COMMITTEE
WITH REGARD TO INTENT OPTICALLY
AROUND SINCE ENHANCEMENTS ARE
AT IT AND I'VE BEEN TO
UNDERSTAND THAT THAT. YES THAT
INTENT IS WE UP TO THE
DISCRETION OF THE ARRESTED
AUTHORITY AND- TIMES IN MY
EXPERIENCE IN THIS WILL BE DEAL
WITH INTENT YOU ALREADY HAVE
POSSESSION OF WHATEVER. IS TO
SELL ITS INTENT TO DO SOMETHING
WITH SOMETHING YOU ALREADY HAVE
A SESSIONS NO. IN TO COME. A
ROBBERY AGAIN I WOULD HAVE
CONCERN IN THAT INTENT WOULD BE
TO FIND- BY. A WILL OF TO THE
REST WITH ALREADY. LASTLY I
WOULD JUST ADD. YOU KNOW THERE
ALSO ARE. YELLS ONLINE IF YOU
LOOK WHERE- YOU KNOW PEOPLE
QUESTION THE RIGHT OF CERTAIN
PEOPLE TO BE THE SPACE. IN FOR
MISS YOU TOO THE ELVES OF
PEOPLE USING A KEY ENTERING BUT
CURRENTLY OF THEIR APARTMENT
BUILDING AND BEING ASKED WHAT
YOU DOING HERE. AND WHAT YOU'RE
WHAT APARTMENT YOU THE END WHEN
THEY HAVE USED THE PASS KEY TO
GET IN THE EXTERIOR DOOR AND SO
PERHAPS THE- HE CELLPHONE IN
THE NEW RING CAMERAS HAVE GIVEN
US ALL A SENSE OF. SOME OF
FORTY THE WE CAN TAKE A FOR US
OFF THE COURT IN THE OUR
INTENT. OTHER I VISIT THIS I
THINK FOR ALL THOSE REASONS I'M
NOT COMFORTABLE THIS MEASURE I
THINK DOESN'T TRULY ADDRESS THE
ISSUE AND- OUR STATE. I HAVE NO
PROBLEM SOME THIRTY CURRENT LAW
GRAND THEFT IF IT'S OVER AND
HUNDRED DOLLARS BUT BUT PUT IN
THE HANDS OF THE ARREST A
SORTIE THE DISCRETION TO
DETERMINE WHETHER MY PRESENCE
THERE SUGGESTS INTO THIS BILL I
TWO FOUR FOR THOSE REASONS I
WILL BE SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY.
NO OTHER COMMENTS FROM MY
COLLEAGUES ON THE DICE I'D LIKE
TO MAKE A COMMENT BEFORE YOU
CLOSE SO WHEN AT. IN OUR- NEW
ODD PANDEMIC CIRCUMSTANCE AND-
WHEN WE WERE- FIRST SITTING
BILLS FOR THE- HEARING I DIDN'T
HAVE ACCESS TO THE COMMITTEES
HOUSES I CERTAINLY HAS TO THE
BILL. AND REPORTER END UP. IN
IT I WAS NOT FULLY AWARE OF THE-
OF WHAT ARE THE OTHER EXISTING
STATUTES AND BASICALLY THE BILL
WOULD BE TO COMPARE AS IT'S
BEEN DISCUSSED HERE WHETHER WE
ARE STATUTES ARE ADEQUATE NOW
THERE'S CERTAIN. YOU THE AUTHOR
AND THE DS. MAY YOUR CASE AS TO
WHY YOU THINK THEY ARE
INADEQUATE HOWEVER I AFTER
REVIEWING THE ANALYSIS AND
ESPECIALLY THE DEBATE DAY. IT
SEEMS TO ME THAT THIS IS. WELL
I CAN CERTAINLY APPRECIATE SOME
PEOPLE FEELING THAT THIS IS
REALLY NECESSARY IT IN FACT
SEEMS REDUNDANT AND THE ISSUE
OF. BEING ABLE TO ALLOW SOMEONE
PROSECUTED FOR INTENT THAT IS A
VERY DIFFICULT THING TO PROVE
I'M VERY COMFORTABLE SOMEONE
BEING PROSECUTED BECAUSE THEY
STOLE PACKAGE EVEN IF THE
PACKAGE WE ON THE FRONT LAWN.
SO THE CURTILAGE ISSUE IS ON IF
YOU SEE. THE ISSUE OF WHETHER
YOU HAPPENED TO BE THERE.
WITHIN TEN OR NOT IS A VERY
HARD IS A VERY SUBJECTIVE AND
SO IN BOTH LISTENING TO THE
DEBATE AND AFTER I WAS EIGHT.
THE ANNOUNCES BY. YEAH I CAN'T
SUPPORT THE BILL IN ITS CURRENT
FORM AND I DO APPRECIATE AND I
THINK BY WHEN MY STAFF IN OUR
FIRST TALKING ABOUT IT I AM
VERY AWARE THAT THERE IS MORE
TO SUPPORT PIRACY. FIRST THIS
IS A KNOW CAN BE CITY. ON FOR.
HOWEVER THEY CAN STILL BE
PROSECUTED FOR THE CRIME IF
THEY STEAL THAT ARE. THAT
PACKAGE SO. THINK OF EXPLAIN
WHERE I'M COMING FROM BUT
CENTER JONES YOU MAY CLOSE
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS AND FIRST OF ALL I WANT
TO A ALLEGE SENATOR AND FURS
CONCERNS OF. SANGRE YOU HAD A
PERCENT THAT. SITUATION IN
GEORGIA IS UNACCEPTABLE AND AS
A SOCIETY AND AS A CULTURE WE
HAVE A LOT OF WORK TO DO.
CONTINUE TO THOSE ISSUES. THANK
YOU FOR ME BRING THAT BRING
THAT TO LIFE FOR ALL OF US HERE
TODAY BECAUSE I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT WE ARE COST
REMINDED. THOSE THIS CULTURE
AND THAT WE CONTINUE TO WORK ON
A- I DO HERE I'M AGREEMENT
TODAY ON THAT THERE THAT
THERE'S A YOU KNOW A- A PROBLEM
THAT THAT IS IN SEARCH OF A
STATION. SO SURE I WOULD LIKE
TO GO AHEAD AND YOU KNOW
THERE'S A MOTION I WOULD LIKE
TO CONTINUE ON WITH THE VOTE. I
WILL CLOSE WITH FIVE THEN-
MADAM CHAIR OF THE BILL COMES
UP SHOR I WOULD YOU KNOW ASKED
SEPARATE IN THEIR MICE OFFEND
ANY STAFF I CAN CONTINUE TO
WORK TO WOULD LIKE TO DO.
QUESTIONS I. MAY NOT THEN WOULD
LOVE TO HEAR THE D. EIGHT ATION
UPPER TO WORK THE OPPONENTS OF
THE OPPOSITE CAN AND SEE IF WE
CAN COME TO YOU KNOW CONCLUDE
FIVE END OF THIS SESSION HERE
FOR ME IS THAT THE DEADLINE AND
SO IF YOU'RE GONNA BE ANOTHER
HEARING. THIS REPORT ALSO
INDICATED THAT SIX CALIFORNIAS
CITIES WERE AMONG THE TOP
TWENTY CITIES. BUT THE MOST ON
PACKAGES IN THE NATION THOSE
CITIES ARE SAN FRANCISCO
OAKLAND SAN JOSE. PLUS IT THIS
ACTOR. STOCKTON AND MODESTO-
WAS SAN FRANCISCO. NOT ONE
NATION THAT OR SEND A IS NOW
OBVIOUS TO BIG ANNIE OKAY
BECAUSE THE D. IS TAKE US ON A
AS A- PROJECT FOR HER. AS I
MENTIONED IN MY OPENING THIS IS
I HAVE NATION WIDE. PUBLIC AND-
LOOKING. AND. HOW TO SOLVE IT
AND JUST LIKE WE DID WITH THE
CHAIRWOMAN'S IN SEAT OF A BILL
WE SEE THIS THE WITHIN A OF
WEEKS. AS A THE REST OF THE
COUNTRY FOLLOWED CAL LEAD ON
THAT ISSUE. I THINK IS WE'VE
ALL I RECOGNIZE THAT ISN'T
THERE ISN'T A. MEETING
ATTENTION TO THE AND THE PUBLIC
IS BECOMING AND MORE AWARE OF
IT AND I THINK WE CAN PUT THE
SAME- THE ENERGY BEHIND THIS
THERE WE HAVE IN OTHER KICK
OTHER BILLS. IN CALIPHATE THAT
HAVE LED THE NATION AND SO-
THIS MORNING I WOULD ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE AND APPRECIATE
YOUR SUPPORT ON THIS BILL. SO I
WANT TO SEE IF THE MOTION IS
THE BILL IN ITS CURRENT FORM OF
THE BILL WITH THE AMENDMENT MY
PREFERENCE WOULD BE THE BILL IN
ITS CURRENT FORM. WE'LL DO THAT.
AND IN THEN THAT IS A IS LEAVE
THE WAFFLER. OKAY PART ANY LAST
COMMENTS BEFORE WE GO TO VOTE.
ALL RIGHT- DISS THE MOTION ON
THE BILL AS INTO IT CORRECT FOR
US GO AHEAD CENTER MAKE THANK
YOU FOR OPENING THAT
OPPORTUNITY I YOU MENTIONED
THAT THIS IS A PROBLEM IN
SEARCH OF A SOLUTION ABSOLUTELY
AGREE WITH YOU. I DON'T THE
SOLUTION. RIGHT YOU'RE BRINGING
A BECAUSE WE DO TO TRY JUST AS
I THINK ABOUT IT IN MAY DE
ATTORNEY IF YOU HAVE SOMEONE
WHO'S TRAILING BEHIND AN AMAZON
TRUCK AND THEY'VE TAKEN THREE
OR FOUR PACKAGES MY SUSPICION.
MAY HAVE THEFT. YOU MAY SHOW
STEP BECAUSE THE- TOTAL AND I
BELIEVE THIS IS ACCURATE YOU
COULD ARGUE IT IS A CONTINUOUS
FACT. NINE HOW DID ALL. SURE
GRANT THEFT WHICH IS A FELLOW
AND THESE FOLK WHO ARE CREATE
THE KIND OF GAME OF A YOU KNOW.
ARE COULD BE AND SHOULD BE
PUNISHED FOR THIS I CHOSE TO
WOULD HAVE TO SAY ALTHOUGH I
PREACH THE SAN I STONE FOR THIS
IS SOLUTION FOR A VERY REAL BUT
I THINK YOU FOR BRINGING THE
BILL IN WORK ON IT THANK YOU
AND AFTER THAT WHY I'M HOPING
WILL HAVE REACHED. BUT ON. AS
THE- CALL THE ROLL SB NINE
SEVENTY NINE DO PASSED
APPROPRIATE SKINNER. INTERNAL
MORE. MOORLACH AYE BROUGH.
BRADFORD NO JACKSON. JAX
MITCHELL NOW MITCHELL NO MORALE.
MORRELL AYE WIENER. NO IN
WINTER NOW. THE BILL ARE THE
FAILS IT'S TO FIVE. VOTE WAS TO
FIVE AN CINDER JONES. I WOULD
JUST A REQUEST WE CONSIDER
PLEASE WE WILL WITH THE
COMMITTEES WE WILL GRANT
FREQUENT. THANK YOU MUCH IN YOU
HAVE A COMMAND TO YOU KNOW MY
STAFF DOUBLE ON WE'RE HARD ON
THE AND SUMMER IS A DH AND I'M
WILL AS WELL AND WILL ENGAGE ME
HE PARTIES IS TO COME UP WITH
THE PROPER MOTION. THANK YOU SO
NOW WE WILL GO TO I. THE
WHATEVER NUMBER FALL PETER
BEFORE THE. TESTIFY RIGHT
BEFORE I BEGIN MY PRESENTATION.
YES WE HAVE ONE OF THE TWO WE
HAVE THE ONE IN SUPPORT THE ONE
IN OPPOSITION IS NOT CURRENTLY
ON THE PHONE LINE BUT I WAS-
WONDERING IF YES GIVE DIRECTOR
FOR OUR CALLERS IN CASE JUST
OFFER PHONE CALL ESTATES ARE
ITS ONE AND THEN THE ZERO TO
PUT YOURSELF IN THE QUEUE. AND.
SO IF YOU WANTED TO IN EITHER
OPPOSITION- SUPPORT. BY YOU CAN.
START YOUR PHONE CALLING SUCH.
PROCEED TO PRESENT. THANK YOU
THE MANAGER I'LL GO AHEAD AND
TAKE CARE OF THE- YES YOU WELL
BECAUSE I HAVE 2% YOU SHOULD DO
THAT PART YES THANK YOU. THANKS
TO RURAL OF. LIKE A IF YOU.
YOUR FREED PRESENT THAT TEN
SUCCESS I'M JUST REGULAR MY NOW.
RIGHT SB TO SIXTY FOUR. CITY
STREET FOR POLICY TO THAT WOULD
PROVIDE DO PRO RIGHTS TO
INCARCERATED ENVISAGE
INDIVIDUALS IN A COMPARABLE NOT
EXACTLY THE SAME MANNER BUT
COMPARABLE MANNER AS WE DO. NOW
TO- DOES USED IN A CRIMINAL
TRIAL. UNCORROBORATED IN
CONFIDENTIAL ACT TIONS FROM IN
PRISON INFORMANT SO IN OTHER
WORDS A CONFIDENTIAL INFORMANT
IS NOW ALLOWED IN CAN BE PUT
INTO A- IN CART INDIVIDUALS
FILE. CAN BE USED DURING A
PAROLE HEARING AND CAN ALSO BE
USED TO JUSTIFY. POLICEMEN
GUIDE INACTION BY THE-
DEPARTMENT FACILITY AGAINST THE
INDIVIDUAL CALIFORNIA EXISTING
LAW BARS THE USE OF SUCH
EVIDENCE IN CRIMINAL TESTIMONY
FOR THE CONVICTION OF
DEFENDANTS UNCORROBORATED AND
CONFIDENTIAL ACCUSATIONS ARE
DEEPLY UNFAIR AND THEY PROVIDE
NO OPPORTUNITY TO USED TO
PROVIDE. THREE TEN SIXTY FOUR.
CDC ARE AND THE PRO ABOARD FOR
MAKING A DECISION THAT RELIES
ON INFO THAT IS NOT PROVEN WITH
EVIDENCE AND TO AND- DUE
PROCESS FIFTY DCR ONCE SAID A-
THE- IN A DRAWER AND THERE A-
MUST FIRST NOTICE INCLUDING A
DESCRIPTION. THE INFORMATION
FOR THE DATE. AND MORE AND THE
WITH THAT I HAVE SOME WITNESSES.
AND YOUR FIRST WITNESSES MISTER
KEITH WIDELY IS THAT CORRECT
YES. STREET WHILE THE YOU HAVE
THE FLOOR. MODERATORS RETAIN OR
NOT AND- MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS KEITH WIDELY- THE
FOUNDER AND EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF THE LAW I'M SPEAKING TO YOU.
TODAY IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
AS WE CAN SIXTY FOUR WE
SUBMITTED A LETTER BUT THEY AGO.
BUT I WELCOME ANY QUESTIONS YOU
MAY HAVE ABOUT THAT BUT I'M
APPEARED TO DO. SOME COPS. OKAY
CALIFORNIA OFFICIALS HAVE
STRONG TOGETHER A BIT IN PEACE
IN NOVEMBER THANK COP I. HELLO
STORY ABOUT WHO'S IN IN ACTIVE
OR OTHER THIS CALM INSIDE ITS
PRISONS. PLEASE ARE NOT ALWAYS
CORROBORATED BY INDEPENDENT
SOURCES STORIES THAT THEY TELL
ABOUT PEOPLE SOMETIMES LEAD TO
FORMAL DISCIPLINARY PROCEEDINGS
AND SOMETIMES PRISON OFFICIALS
USE THE STORIES. COULD DECIDE
WHO COULD BE HOUSE WITH. ALL
WHO DON'T IN LONG TERM SOLITARY
CONFINEMENT. OTHER TIMES THE
STORIES LANDED A PERSON'S
COULDN'T FILE ONLY TO BE PICKED
UP YEARS A DECADE LATER. BOB
DOLE COMMISSIONERS TRYING TO
DECIDE WHETHER POLICE THE
PERSONAL GLOBAL. IF YOU WOULD
MAKE SUCH A OF THE- USED AS A
READ FOR THE AND FOR ALL. SB
SIXTY FOUR WILL THAT SUCH A- OF
MISSED BE COOPER BY TRUE
INDEPENDENT SOURCES. I'LL ALSO
BRING MORE FAIRNESS TO THE FULL
CONSIDERATION PROCESS BY
REQUIRING THAT THE PAROLE BOARD
ONLY RELY ON ALLEGATIONS THAT
HAVE EITHER BEEN ADMITTED OR
PROVEN TO BE TRUE. PROCESS THAT
ALLOW BECAUSE A MEANINGFUL. TO
KNOW ABOUT RESPOND TO AN APPEAL
THE USE OF THOSE ALLEGATIONS
VERY PLEASED TO SUPPORT THIS.
AND I HOPE YOU WILL TOO THANK
YOU THANK YOU FOR WHAT WE DO WE
ALSO HAVE A MAGNET NINETY ON
THE FLOOR ON THE LINE. AS HER
LINE IS RETRIEVED WILL HAVE HER
IN HERE MOMENTARILY. WE'RE
STILL FOCUSED ON A THREE MINUTE
THE- LINDA THANK YOU LAURA
MACNIDER LINE IS OPEN YOU MAY
PROCEED. THANK YOU THIS IS
SENATOR SKINNER AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS LAURA
MAGNANI AND I'M PROGRAM
DIRECTOR FOR HEALING JUSTICE
FOR THE AMERICAN FRIENDS
SERVICE COMMITTEE CAN YOU HEAR
ME YES THANK YOU WELCOME. I
HAVE. THANK YOU I HAVE JST A
COUPLE OF THINGS TO ADD TO
MISTER WHAT LEAST TESTIMONY. ON
MONDAY HUNDREDS OF PEOPLE
FORMALLY INCARCERATED CAME TO A
VIRTUAL LOBBY DAY. AND SEVERAL
OF THEM SPOKE ON SB TEN SIXTY
FOUR AND WHY IT WAS SO
IMPORTANT. I JUST WANT TO
CAPTURE A COUPLE. AMPLE SAID
WERE GIVEN THAT DAY ONE.
DESCRIBED THE THIRTY SEVEN
YEARS HER HUSBAND HAD ALREADY
SERVED FOR SECOND DEGREE.
MURDER TWENTY NINE OF THEM FOR
SOLITARY CONFINEMENT HE'S
EARNED HIS G. ET AND THREE
EIGHT DEGREES AND HAS TWENTY
SELF HELP CERTIFICATE CATIONS
SINCE THE. TWENTY TWENTY TWO TO
TWENTY TO. HIS LAST RULES
VIOLATION. I CAN'T SEEM TO BE
HEARD CAN YOU HEAR ME YOU'RE
DOING BUT YOUR TIME IS RUNNING.
OKAY WELL SHE SHE SAID THAT I
WAS DONE SO ME KEEP GO. HE WAS
DENIED FOR PURPLE FOR FIFTEEN
YEARS BASED ENTIRELY ON
CONFIDENTIAL INFORMATION IN HIS
FILE THIS LAST RULES VIOLATIONS
IN TWENTY THIRTEEN FOR HAVING
AS TECH PART IN THIS PROPERTY.
HE HAD NO RIGHT. NINETEEN
EIGHTY. FIFTEEN REGARDLESS OF
THE FACTS WILL BE A FAIR HI SO
THAT'S JUST ONE EXAMPLE THAT
WAS REALLY COMPELLING THAT CAME
OUT IN THAT DAY THE DECISIONS
BEING MADE ON THE FEDERAL LEVEL
MATERIAL. HERE'S MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS BECAUSE THAT SO MANY
YEARS TO PEOPLE'S
INCARCERATIONS. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISS MAGNANI
APPRECIATED. DO WE HAVE ANY
WITNESSES IN THE ROOM THAT WISH
TO SPEAK ON BEHALF OF. SB TEN
SIXTY FOUR. SEEING NONE ARE
THERE ANY WITNESSES IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY THAT WISH TO SPEAK
SEEING NONE. OPERATOR DO WE
HAVE- ANY INDIVIDUALS ON THE
LINE THAT WISH TO SPEAK ON
BEHALF OF SB TEN SIX OR- WE
HAVE OVER A DOZEN I'LL
REITERATE ITS ONE AND ZERO TO
PLACE YOURSELF INTO THE QUEUE.
HOLE FOR START OUT ONLINE
NUMBER SEVENTY FIVE SEVEN FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN AND THE GOAL
IS TO GIVE YOUR NAME YOUR
LOCATION THANK YOU. LINE
SEVENTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
FOR EXAMPLE THAT WAS REALLY
YOUR OWN MOVE NO RESPOND EASEL
ONION. DOLLARS NOT RESPONDING
TO THAT- WILL GO AHEAD AND MOVE
ON TO WHY NUMBER THIRTY ONE
LINE THREE ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. BLIND SIR ON ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. I WAS GIVEN THREE
ONE BUT I'M IN OPPOSITION. ROOM
WHICH IS BEING STAY ON THE LINE
THEN PLEASE OKAY WE'LL CIRCLE.
CIRCLE BACTERIA THANK YOU WHAT
A LINE NUMBER SIXTY SIX SIX SIX
OUR LINE IS OPEN. CAN BE ANY
COLOR ON THE HAPPENED SAN
FRANCISCO PUBLIC DEFENDER'S
OFFICE AND VERY STRONG PART OF
THE SPELL. SEVENTY FIVE. YOU
WILL GO TO LINE NUMBER SEVENTY
ONE SEVEN ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU LESLIE CALDWELL
HOUSTON FOR THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION IN
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU WILL
GO TO LINE NUMBER SEVENTY THREE
SEVEN FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
YEAH THAT- ISRAELI NEARLY OF
THE PORT. THANK YOU. BY NUMBER
EIGHTY THREE EIGHT THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HE STARTED WITH
INITIATE DOESN'T STRONG SUPPORT.
THREE ONE MODERATOR OF IT WILL
GO TO LINE NUMBER EIGHTY FOUR
MODERATORS SOUNDS LIKE SOMEONE
IS NOT I'M YOU TO WEAR HEARING
BACKGROUND NOISE HOW DO WE A
STRETCH TO SWITCH OUT ONLY TO
SWITCH OUT AND MEET THAT LINE
PLEASE WITH ME A MOMENT WHILE I
GO UP SWITCHED. THANK YOU. OKAY
BELIEVE I'VE CORRECTED THE
PROBLEM WILL NOW GO TO LINE
NUMBER TWENTY EIGHT TO EIGHT TO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I ASK YOUR
HERNANDEZ HOW CALIFORNIA
ATTORNEYS FOR CRIMINAL JUSTICE
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL. THANK
YOUTHANK YOU BYE NUMBER EIGHTY
FOUR EIGHT FOR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. YEAH WELL IN STATE THE
LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR FOR THE
PEACE ALLIANCE WE ARE IN VERY
STRONG SUPPORTER OF THIS MAJOR.
YOU. WE'LL NOW GO TO LINE
NUMBER EIGHTY FIVE EIGHT FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
JIM LINDBERGH ON BEHALF OF THE
FRIENDS COMMITTEE ON
LEGISLATION IN CALIFORNIA IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF SB TEN SIXTY
FOUR THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NUMBER LINE NUMBER
SIXTY TWO SIX TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. YEAH THIS IS MAGGIE HIRED
FOR THE CALIFORNIA CIVIL
LIBERTIES ADVOCACY WE ARE ALSO
TRANSPORT SB TEN SIXTY FOUR.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU LINE
NUMBER SEVENTY NINE SEVEN NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THE ONE.
THANK AFFORDABLE STILL THANK.
THANK YOU BYE NUMBER FORTY
EIGHT FOUR EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD MORNING THIS IS
MARCO GEORGE ALSO ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION AND STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU. BY NUMBER
EIGHTY TWO EIGHT TO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. MIKE A DOCTOR OFF ON
BEHALF OF THE ACLU OF
CALIFORNIA AND STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU LINE
NUMBER SEVENTY SEVEN ZERO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI THIS IS
GREGORY COULD ALSO WITH
INITIATE JUSTICE IN VERY STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. LINE NUMBER
EIGHTY NINE EIGHT NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. TO MINGLE WITH
PHIL CONNELLY DE BY GOING
STRONG SUPPORTER THE STILL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. BY NUMBER
NINETY NINE ZERO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. BY NINETY CAN YOU CHECK
YOUR LINE FOR MUTE FOR HEARING
AUDIO. MY NAME IS JACK MORRIS I
WILL CONSTRAIN JOHNS WELL
CHARLIE FAMILY CENTERS I IN
SUPPORT OF IS BEACON SIXTY FOUR
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. AND THAT
CONCLUDES SECURE AT THIS TIME
PLEASE CONTINUE THANK YOU
MODERATOR THAT TAKES IS NOW TO
THOSE IN. OF SB TEN SIXTY FOUR.
DO WE HAVE ANY WITNESSES THAT
WISH TO IF THAT TAKE ADVANTAGE
OF THE THREE MINUTE OPPORTUNITY.
DO WE HAVE ANYONE IN THIS
COMMITTEE ROOM. DO WE HAVE
ANYONE IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY.
SEEING NONE IN BOTH LET'S GO TO
THE LINES MISTER MODERATOR DO
WE HAVE ANY. INDIVIDUALS THAT
WOULD TO SPEAK. IN OPPOSITION
TO SB WHICH IS SIXTY FOUR.
CERTAINLY IF YOU'D LIKE TO
SPEAK OUT IN OPPOSITION ON THE
PHONE LINES THE INSTRUCTIONS
ARE ONE THEN THE ZERO ON YOUR
TELEPHONE EYPAD WE'LL GO TO
LINE NUMBERS SEVENTY THREE
SEVEN THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
LINE SEVENTY THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. ARE YOU WITH THE
CALIFORNIA DISTRICT ATTORNEYS
ASSOCIATION. DO I HAVE A
WITNESS FROM THE CALIFORNIA
DISTRICT ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION
MISTER MODERATOR. I WOULD NOT
KNOW UNLESS YOU CAN PROVIDE
THEIR NAMES OKAY I ONLY HAVE
LINE NUMBERS ON MY SCREEN- I DO
HAVE TWO MORE THAT ARE IN THE
QUEUE WILL SEE IF ONE OF THEM
IS WHO YOU'RE LOOKING FOR
LITTLE LINE NUMBER. THREE
NINETY THREE WHAT IS A- HI MY
NAME IS BUT NAY THEIR HEART I'M
WITH SILICON VALLEY DEBUG AND
I'M IN SUPPORT. OF AND BEFORE.
THANK YOU WE HAVE A LATE COMER
IN SUPPORT WE HAVE NOW LINE
NUMBERS THIRTY ONE THREE ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YES MY NAME
IS TODD GRAVY. GOOD MORNING
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS. OF THE
DISTRICT ATTORNEY OF AMADOR
COUNTY AND I'M HERE ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION. WE'RE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED TO SB TEN
SIXTY FOUR. PART OF MY ELECTION
I WAS THE CHIEF PBLIC DEFENDER
PARAMETER COUNTY AND IT THAT
THE PUBLIC DEFENDER MADERA
COUNTY. SINCE NINETEEN NINETY
ONE A BIGGER DEFENDED A MAJOR
PROSECUTED THEM. I'M PAST
PRESENT. A CULTURE OF THE CDA
LIKE FOR PROCESS. CAN I'M NOT
BUT THE PRESENT CAN. AND A
BONDING MEMBER THE PRISON
CRIMES COUNCIL ALSO HAVE A
PRESIDENT BILL CREEK WHICH IN
MY JURISDICTION. SB TEN SIXTY
FOUR WOULD DEPRIVE SHUSHI ARE
FROM USING RELIABLE EVIDENCE OF
THEM MAKE CRIMINAL ACTIVITY.
HOLD THEM ACCOUNTABLE
DISCIPLINARY HEARINGS GIVE A
CALL. SINCE IT BE PHD WHO CAN
ROB CRIMINAL IN FROM AND AN
MAKE SURE REVIEW BY ONE AND
JEOPARDIZE THE SAFETY OF
INMATES CITIZENS IN QUESTION
STAFF FIRST AND FOREMOST SB TEN
TO KEEP AND THAT'S JEFF
SESSIONS TRUCKS AND ALREADY
WITHIN LAW TO IN SURE IT JUST
PROCEEDINGS AND OF BEFORE WILL
SHOOT. WHAT INFORMATION THAT'S
JUST THE RIGHTS AND A FOR TO
PRY. SB TEN SIX FOUR WILL LINK
THE NUMBER THE NEXT TO JUST
PROCEEDING TO GO FORWARD SO
THEY CAN OBTAIN ALL THE
INFORMATION REGARDING
INFORMANTS JUDGES ARE NAMED A
DETAILED DESCRIPTION OF THE
INFORMATION PROVIDED. TURN IT
WAS EITHER DEFENDER PROCESS
PRISON CRIMES FOR TWENTY NINE
YEARS THAT IS AS GOOD AS A
DEPTH. IN PERSON SETTING.
BOTTOM LINE IT. DOESN'T TAKE TO
SHARE VALUABLE INFORMATION AS
YOU SEE OUR PROSECUTORS. BY THE
END NAY AND THOSE ON THAT IMAGE
HAPPY. SB CANCER FOUR WILL
JEOPARDIZE LONG TERM ONGOING
INVESTIGATIONS INTO DANGEROUS
ACTING PLACING CITIES GUARD PH
IN THE UNTENABLE POSITION OF
DECIDING WHETHER TO USE A
CONFIDENTIAL INFORMATION. I WAS
JEOPARDIZING ANY ON GOING
INVESTIGATION OR FOR GO IT
USING CHARLIE WAS ALL BUT
ASSURING THAT THE AND MAKE WILL
BE FOUND NOT THE AT THE JUST.
WILL BE FOUND. FOR PAROLE.
PROSECUTE CRY OCCURRING AT NEW
CREE STATE PRISON A FEW YEARS
AGO WE HAD A KEY FROM OF A GANG
DECIDE TO ATTACK CORRECTIONAL
OFFICER. THE MANUFACTURES AND
FOR YEARS BY THE ASSAILANTS. IN
A FORM STEP FORWARD AND
PROVIDED INFORMATION ABOUT THE
PLANNED ATTACK. AS A RESULT OF
THIS INFORMATION THE WEAPONS
WERE FOUND. JACK BOARD.
INFORMANT INFORMATION LIKELY
SAVED THE LIFE. SB TEN SIXTY
FOUR WILL UP AND THE PEARL
SHOULD ABILITY AND NON VIOLENT
FULL PROCESS FORENSIC
PSYCHOLOGIST WILL BE DEPRIVED
OF RELEVANT INFORMATION
CRITICAL TO DETERMINE IN NATURE
AS FOR TEACHER VIOLENCE THIS
INSURE BUT DEPRIVED PH FROM
COMPLETE AND ACCURATE RISK
ASSESSMENT WHEN THEY GET SHOULD
ABILITY JUST. TEMPERATURES WERE
ALL. HOW CAN I NATION MISTER
JESTER ATTORNEY NERI HEARINGS
WHERE THE INMATE WAS FOUND NOT
GUILTY. BECAUSE THEY WERE
INTEREST IN FACT NOT GUILTY BUT
BECAUSE THEY WERE SUCCESSFUL
INTIMIDATING INFORMATIVE
RELEVANT INFORMATION AGAIN SOME
PUMP COOPER FONG RESTAURANT
SURE CAN YOU I BELIEVE. I'VE
GOTTEN. ALL RESIDENTS PRESENTLY
THE BILL GRAYSON ONYX RISK OF
SAFETY DAY AND THEY SHE DO YOU
SEE A JERRY WHAT THE DOOR. TO
THANK YOU AMADOR D. A. TODD
ROOM IS A REPEAT. YES THANK YOU
THANK YOU IN A LITTLE OVER TIME
BUT I THINK YOU GET YOUR POINT
IN OUR BUT THANK YOU FOR
PARTICIPATING TODAY TO- MISTER
MODERATOR DO WE HAVE ANY OTHER
IT THE PARTICIPANTS WE SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO. SB TEN SIX FOUR.
I HAVE ONE MORE IN THE QUEUE
OVER THE LINE NUMBER ONE
HUNDRED AND ONE ONE A ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. I DON'T ON MAY
MANY AND ROLE TO DO JUSTICE
COALITION ACTIONS OF. SUPPORT
OF. SIX FOUR. THANK YOU. MISTER
MODERATOR YOU AT THIS TIME
PLEASE GREAT THEN THAT TAKES US
NOW TO- MY COLLEAGUES ON THE
COMMITTEE- ANYONE WISHING TO
ASK THE AUTHOR ANY QUESTIONS AT
THIS TIME. DO I HAVE BY ANY MY
COLLEAGUES WISHING TO MAKE A
MOTION. THE MOVED TIONS GO WITH
SENATOR BRADFORD. ANY OTHER
FURTHER DISCUSSION BY MY
COLLEAGUES THING NINE. CENTER
SKINNER WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
THANK YOU ARE. PRE SHAKE THE
INFERRED FROM THE VARIOUS
WITNESSES AND ON THE DA'S POINT
I THINK THE- YEAH. THERE'S A
BASIC DUE PROCESS RIGHT
REGARDLESS OF WHERE A PERSON
IS- WHETHER THEY ARE
INCARCERATED INDIVIDUAL OR
PERSON WHO IS ACCUSED OF A
CRIME IN- JUST A CRIMINAL TRIAL
AND WHY WE ALLOW FOR A DOUBLE
JEOPARDY OF ON BOTH OPERATED
AND CONFIDENTIAL ACCUSATIONS IN
THIS SETTING WHEN WILL BE A
STATUTORILY WOULD NOT ALLOW IT
TO BE IN A CONVICTION ON. IT
REALLY MAKES SENSE SO I THINK
THAT THERE IS GOOD DUE PROCESS
BUILT INTO THE BILL. IT DOES
NOT EXCLUDE THE ABILITY FOR-
ACCUSATIONS- TO BE MADE AND SO-
WITH THAT I WOULD ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE ON SB TEN SIXTY FOUR.
THANK YOU SENATOR SKINNER MADAM
SIR WOULD YOU PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. THE TENSE BEFORE MOTION
IS DUE PASSED TO APPROPRIATE.
SKINNER FIVE. CAN R. I. MORE
LOCK MORE LOCK HI BRADFORD.
BRADFORD AYE JACKSON. MITCHELL
PINE MITCHELL AYE MORALE WELL
NO WINNER. HI WIENER I THAT
SERVE FIVE ONE AND WE HAVE TO
HOLD THE ROLE OPEN FOR ONE OF
OUR MEMBERS AND SO MADAM CHAIR
THE MEETING IS NOW YOURS AGAIN.
THANK YOU MISTER REISS CHAIR-
WE WILL NOW MOVE TO SB. ONE ONE
ONE ONE BY SENATOR DERIVE SO
AND WE WILL FOLLOW THAT SINCE
YOU HAVE TO BILLS SENATOR DR SO
WE WILL FOLLOW THAT WITH YOUR
BILL SB TWELVE NINETY BUT WE
WILL START JUST WITH SB. ONE
ONE ONE ONE SENATOR DRUGS SO
YOU MAY PROCEED TO FIRST. IN
THIS BILL SIGNED AS DETENTION
FACILITIES TO THE NORTH. THANK
YOU BOB MORE OF MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE-
SENATE BILL BY ELEVEN ELEVEN
AMENDS CALIFORNIA LAW TO PERMIT
YOU TO STAY IN JUVENILE
FACILITIES. PENDING THE OUTCOME
OF THEIR JIM JUVENILE COURT
CASE UNTIL THE AGE OF TWENTY
ONE. THIS BILL CREATES A
THOUGHTFUL PROCESS FOR
DETERMINING WHETHER YOUTH. AGE
EIGHT TO TWENTY ONE WHOSE CASES
ORIGINATED IN AN ALL COURT
SHOULD BE IN ADULT JAILS. IT
CREATE PRESUMPTION FOR KEEPING
NEWS AND JUVENILE FACILITIES
AND REQUIRES THAT A JUDGE
DECIDE WHETHER YOU MAY BE
MOVED. PROVIDES GUIDANCE FOR A
JUDGE'S DECISION CURRENT LAW
PROVIDES NO STANDARDS FOR THIS
DECISION. OF THE YOUTH TO BE
MOVED TO AN ADULT JAIL IF THE
JUVENILE FACILITY SAFELY CARE
FOR THEM OR IF THE PHYSICAL
SPACE COULD NOT COMMENT ON
OLDER POPULATION. SIMPLY BY
SALAS THE RULES FOR DIFFERENT.
OF YOUTH INCLUDING YOU AND YUBA
COURT. AN YOUTH WHO HAVE BEEN
ORDERED TRANSFERRED TO THE
ADULT COURT. OF THE VAST
MAJORITY OF INCARCERATED YOUTH
IN CALIFORNIA ARE HELD IN
COUNTY LEVEL FACILITIES. IN HIS
MAY REVISION THE GOVERNOR
PROPOSES TO SHUT DOWN THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUVENILE JUSTICE
FACILITIES. IF THIS IS ADOPTED
ANY NEW CALIFORNIA YOUTH
OFFENDERS WILL BE HOUSED IN
COUNTY JUVENILE FACILITIES. A
DOZEN ORGANIZATIONS LIST THIS
BILL AS PART OF FOR
RECOMMENDATIONS TO THE GOVERNOR
TO ENSURE THAT REALIGNMENT
PROMOTE EQUITY AND CHILD WELL
BEING. ALTHOUGH THERE ARE SPLIT
POLICY REASONS- MAY TO
INTRODUCE THIS BILL IT PROVIDE
IT IT'S PROPOSED MECHANISMS ARE
IMPORTANT DURING THIS CALL BUT
NINETEEN PANDEMIC. BECAUSE THEY
WOULD REDUCE THE TRACK OF
DISEASE AN EASE DITIONS FOR
STAFF TASKED WITH MODERATE
MONITORING. YOUNGER INMATES IN
ADULT FACILITIES I JUST ONE AND
BY READING THE WORDS OF- FATHER
MIKE KENNEDY OF THE JESUIT
RESTORATIVE JUSTICE INITIATIVE.
HE SAYS WHEN A YOUTH IS
TRANSFERRED FROM JUNE UP
JUVENILE HALL TO THE COP BILL
IT IS A SHOT. THEY LEAVE
JUVENILE. TOOL IS RE. IS
AVAILABLE AND AGE APPROPRIATE
TREATMENT ACTIVITIES TAKE
PLACE. AND THEY ARE PUT IN THE
COUNTY JAIL WHICH HAS NONE OF
THESE OPPORTUNITIES THEIR HOUSE
WITH OLDER PEOPLE. OFTEN IN
CROWDED IN BILINGUE CONDITIONS.
IT QUICKLY BECOMES CLEAR THAT
THEIR ONLY TASK IS TO SURVIVE.
SO THE STATE OF LEARNING IN
SCHOOL. THEY LEARN HOW TO GET
ALONG WITH THE GANGS AND AVOID
BEING ASSAULTED. HE GOES ON TO
SAY I AM NO FAN OF JUVENILE
HALL I MIGHT BE FIRST IN LINE
TO TESTIFY YOU BE HELD A
HEARING. ABOUT THE BECAUSE THE
CAR I'M IT CAUSES OUR CHILDREN.
HOWEVER JAIL IS MANY MANY TIMES
WORTH IT IS NO PLACE FOR A
YOUNG PERSON. IN ADDITION TO
THE VIOLENCE AND OLDER GANG
MEMBER INFLUENCE IS I FEEL LIKE
SENDS A MESSAGE TO THESE KIDS.
IS THE SWEET. THIS IS YOUR PATH.
THANK YOU OF ALL EGGS AND THERE
IS SUPPORT OF SB ELEVEN ELEVEN.
I WOULD LIKE TO INTRODUCE MY
OUR EXPERT WITNESSES. OF TAKING
UP THE THREE MINUTES WILL BE ST
LOUIS EXIT. AND TIGRESS THEM
COALITION. HERE TO ANSWER ANY-
QUESTIONS THE EXPERT QUESTIONS
WE ALSO HAVE ELIZABETH CALVIN
FROM HUMAN RIGHTS WATCH AND
SUPER RALPH FROM PACIFIC
JUVENILE DEFENDER CENTER. GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR- INDISTINCT
MEDIA CAN CAN EVERYONE HEAR ME.
YES I JUST WANT TO CLARIFY
THERE IS THREE MINUTES TOTAL
AND SO IF YOU'RE USING THREE
WITNESSES AND THEIR TOTAL. IS
ONLY THREE MINUTES. INTO IN
TOTAL NOT INDIVIDUALLY AND SENT
OUT THE- MISTER LEWIS WILL TAKE
UP ON THE THREE MINUTES AND THE
OTHERS WILL BE AVAILABLE FOR
QUESTIONS GREAT THANK YOU GO
AHEAD MISTER LEWIS. THANK YOU
AND GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
UNDERSTAND COMMITTEE- MY NAME
IS SAM LOOKS I'M THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF A R. C. THE ANTI
RECIDIVISM COALITION. AN
ORGANIZATION COMPRISED OF OVER
FIFTEEN HUNDRED MEMBERS WILL
FORMALLY INCARCERATED YOU. FOR
THE FIRST BUT FOR THE LAST FIVE
YEARS I'VE SPENT NEARLY EVERY
SATURDAY EVENING. AND ARE YOU
YOU'LL ALL- WHAT I. WANT
CHILDREN AND I CAN SIT IN
CHILDREN TURN EIGHTEEN EVEN IF
THEIR CASE TAUGHT IN JUVENILE
COURT MEAN YOU'RE MOVED TO.
FROM THE JUVENILE AND CENTER
COUNTY JOKED A LITTLE OR NO
REASON- WHAT ACTUALLY HAPPENED
TO THE JEWS LEADS ME TO BE A
STRONG SUPPORT OF SENATE BILL
ELEVEN ELEVEN. THE BILL WOULD
ELEVEN WOULD ASSURE THAT YOUNG
PEOPLE CONTINUE TO GET.
FRIEDMAN AND THE JULY ALL CASE
ARE. THERE'S A DAHLE J.
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN EDUCATE
COUNSELING AND OTHER HELP STOP.
BIG BOGUS ONLY A MARKS BY THEN
A- THE WHOLE. ENVIRONMENT. I'VE
HEARD MANY STORIES IT OUR BRAVE
FROM A ARE MEMBERS. FROM OTHERS
ACROSS THE STATE I LIKE THIS
TO. THE STORES WOULD YOU ARE
PERSONALLY MENTOR CONTINUE TO
MENTOR. IBM INTO A JORDAN
HINGED HALL WHEN YOU SIXTY I
WATCHED HIM. AND BEGIN TO TAKE
RESPONSE FOR ITS CHOICES IN
LIFE AND REALLY A SO CATION
MAYBE TURN EIGHTEEN AND FOR
LATER WAS. TO THE BOAT. ALMOST
A MILLION HE WAS EIGHT ZERO WHO
HAVE BEEN TRANSFERRED ALSO
NEARLY BEATEN. IN THE SHOWER.
YOU'RE JUST TO GET IT STRAIGHT
FROM BEING AND THAT PROBLEM BY
BY RIGHT. CLEARLY JOINT IS IN
THE BUSINESS HELLO YOU'RE NOT
JUST DOING AND COMING SOON.
AGAIN MENTORING KEVIN WHEN HE
WAS EIGHTEEN TO WOULDN'T. HE
REFUSED TO WHY DON'T YOU JUST
BE AFTER MENTAL AND NICK TO TRY
BEGIN A REAL APPLYING. HIGH
SCHOOL KEVIN EVEN BEGIN AT IS
TEACHERS TO GET THEM ACT WORK
TO DO IN THE STATE OF. SELECT
AS EIGHTEEN BIRTHDAY KEVIN.
EXTRA HOMEWORK TO TEACH REFUSED
IN THE X. HOMEWORK. TRANSCRIPT
DOLLAR JAIL KEVIN TOLD ME THE
VERY FIRST DAY THAT HE ENTERED
THE COUNTY JAIL SOMEONE PRESS
TWO MINISTERS FOR NO REASON IT
DESCRIBES CAUGHT- IN THE COUNTY
JAIL AND THE WORST AND EVER.
KEVIN DOES NOT UNDERSTAND WHY
HE WAS SENT TO JAIL AFTER
REALLY WORKING HARD TO IMPROVE
MY SKILLS AND WE LEARNED LATER
THAT KEVIN ACTUALLY HAD A
LEARNING DISABILITY THAT HE
BEGAN OVERCOME WHAT HE HAD
TREATMENT AND EDUCATIONAL
BILLABLE. DRIVEN ARGUE TO JUDGE
THE DAHLE GEL SO THE WRONG
MESSAGE IN A RUSH THEIR ABILITY
TO HEAL AND GROW I RESPECTFULLY
URGE OF YOUR YES WALDRON IS
BUILD UP SO THAT WE DO NOT
CRUSH THE FUTURE ABOUT SHOOTING
AS WE TRY TO GET THEM BACK ON
THE RIGHT TRACK THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME. THANK YOU MISTER
LEWIS. WE WILL NOW GO TO. THE
WITNESSES SINCE THE- FIRST AS-
YOU WILL ASKING WERE IN THIS
ROOM. AND THIS IS YOUR NAME.
NOW HOW SEEING NINE THAT ARE
ACTUALLY PHYSICALLY IN THE
HEARING ROOM WE WILL LOOK TO
THE SECOND FLOOR HEARING ROOM.
THERE ARE NONE THERE. SO NOW
MODERATOR. IF THERE ARE ANY
FOLKS WHO ARE WANTING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB ELEVEN
ELEVEN WHO ARE ON THE LINE YOU
CAN Q. THE MARK. AS A REMINDER
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN IS ZERO
AT THIS TIME. WE WILL BEGIN
WITH LINE NUMBER SIXTY NINE SIX
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
DOMINIQUE NON CHILDREN'S
DEFENSE FUND CALIFORNIA IT
STRUCK A CHORD. THANK YOU. NOW
GO TO LINE ONE HUNDRED AND TWO
ONE ZERO TO YOUR LINE IS.
ISRAEL WE ARE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LINE FOR YOU THANK
DOCTOR INSTRUCT THE PORT THANK
YOU. ABOUT A LINE NUMBER
SEVENTY SIX SEVEN SIX YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. WHAT CLICK ON THAT
WOULD BE BURNED IN SHORT ORDER.
THANK YOU ON THE LINE ONE
HUNDRED AND SEVEN ONE ZERO
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MY
NAME IS ST THE MANDELA TELECOM
BALLY DEBUGGER PROUD CO
SPONSORED THE BILL AND SUPPORT
THE BILL THANK YOU. AND MY
NUMBER ONE HUNDRED ONE ZERO
ZERO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MY NAME
IS A FAILURE CHAVEZ AND I'M
WITH TELECOM VALLEY DEBUG AND
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THE BILL.
YOU'LL GO TO LINE ONE HUNDRED
AND EIGHTY TWO ONE ZERO EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THE MORNING
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MIND ME GAL
GARCIA- POLICY COORDINATOR FOR
THE ANTI REDEVELOPMENT
SACRAMENTO AND WE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF IT ELEVEN ELEVEN
THANK YOU. CAROLINE ONE HUNDRED
NINE ONE ZERO NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS WESLEY SAY
RUN BEHALF OF GLIDING IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. DO A GROWING
NUMBER EIGHTY TWO EIGHT TWO
YOUR LINE IS. MIKE DOCTOR OFF
ON BEHALF OF THE A FEELING OF
CALIFORNIA AND STRONG COURT
THANK YOU. NEXT IS LINE ONE
HUNDRED AND THIRTEEN ONE ONE
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. JOSH
MINUTE INTEREST IN THE
COALITION STRONG SUPPORT. NEXT
UP IS LINE ONE HUNDRED AND
FOURTEEN ONE ONE FOR YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GENERAL UNSTABLE TURN
FOR THE PEACEFUL LYING IN
SUPPORT OF SB. ELEVEN ELEVEN.
TEXTURES LINE ONE HUNDRED AND
FIFTEEN ONE ONE FIVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. MY NAME IS BARELY
COMPLEX AND I'M WITH CERTAIN
VALLEY DEBUG AND I'M JUST
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE BILL. TWO
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. NOT
SURE HERNANDEZ ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ATTORNEYS FOR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL. ONE ONE HUNDRED AND
ONE ONE ZERO ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. NOT THE REMEDY JUST
COLLISION AND SUPPORT THE BILL.
FIND ONE HUNDRED AND FOUR ONE
ZERO FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING THIS IS THE NAME
THAT HARDWOOD SILICON VALLEY
DEBUG AND WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS BILL. TEXAS LINE ONE
HUNDRED AND THREE ONE ZERO
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THE
MORNING MY NAME IS RAYMOND
BONNER WITH THE ACCURACY OF IT
DIDN'T COALITION WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT. IN THE- YEAH. THANK
YOU NEXT UP IS LINE ONE HUNDRED
AND SIX ONE ZERO SIX YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HELLO COMING MORE
SPEED AND THOMAS W. COLLISION
AND I'M A STRONG SUPPORTER THIS
BILL. CAN NEXT UP IS LINE
SEVENTY EIGHT SEVEN EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HEY GOOD MORNING
THIS IS- CAN'T MENTAL SO
DOWNTURN CITIZEN COALITION IN
STRONG SUPPORTER OF THIS BILL
THANK YOU. TEXAS LINE ONE
HUNDRED AND TEN ONE ONE ZERO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME
IS GALINA CHEAPENED ON BEHALF
OF THE ENTIRE SET OF THAT
COALITION WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS THEM. NEXUS LINE SEVENTY
FOUR SEVEN FOR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD MORNING THIS IS
KAELIN DEAN WITH THE ALLIANCE
FOR BOYS AND MEN OF COLOR AT
POLICY LINK IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF THE BILL. BUT A LINE ONE
HUNDRED AND EIGHTEEN ONE ONE
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YES
THEY ARE JIM LIMBURG ON BEHALF
THE FRIENDS COMMITTEE ON
LEGISLATION OF CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT THANKS. NEXT IS WHY
NUMBER SIXTY SIX SIX SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. DEMOCRATS ARE NAM
HAPPENED THE TECHNOLOGICAL
PUBLIC DEFENDER'S OFFICE HE TO
PORT. NEXT IS LINE ONE HUNDRED
AND TWENTY FIVE ONE TWO FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
MY NAME IF YOU WANT TO LOOK AT
MY WITH THE LOOK ON RALLY. AND
WE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
BILL THANK YOU. EXCEPT LINE
NUMBER SIXTY TWO SIX TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. FIND SIXTY TWO
CAN YOU CHECK YOUR LINE FOR ME
TO STATUS. YEAH THIS IS LARRY
HIGHER FROM THE CALIFORNIA
CIVIL LIBERTIES ADVOCACY WE ARE
ALSO IN STRONG SUPPORT. LINE
WANTED IN TWENTY SEVEN ONE TO
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO
THIS IS PROBABLY OUT OF CHRISTY
WITH COMMUNITY WORKS WE'RE IN
STRONG SUPPORT. LINE ONE
HUNDRED AND TWENTY EIGHT ONE
TWO EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
YES MY NAME IS JACK MORE. ST
JOHN'S WELL TRODDEN FAMILY
CENTER AND WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF
IS THE ONE ONE ONE ONE THANK
YOU. ORDER LINE ONE HUNDRED AND
TWENTY NINE ONE TWO NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MORNING THIS IS
ELIZABETH CALVIN HUMAN RIGHTS
WATCH IS PROUD TO BE A CO
SPONSOR AND WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
SB ELEVEN ELEVEN. AND LINE ONE
HUNDRED AND THIRTY THREE ONE
THREE THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING THIS IS LESLIE
CALDWELL HOUSTON FOR CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT. LINE ONE HUNDRED AND
THIRTY FOUR ONE THREE FOR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. BUT AIMS Q.
LOYOLA. SILICON VALLEY DEBUG
STRONG SUPPORT ENGINEER LEVEL
ELEVEN ALSO AS A PARENT. OF THE-
THANK YOU WILL GO TO LINE
NUMBER FORTY EIGHT FOUR EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. BLIND FORTY
EIGHT WILL YOU CHECK YOURSELF
FOR MUTE. DURING A RESPONSE
SOMEONE FORTY EIGHT WILL MOVE
ON TO LINE ONE HUNDRED AND
THIRTY EIGHT ONE THREE EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME
IS DOMINIQUE DAVIS AND I'M IN
FULL SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. THAT
DOES EXHAUSTED Q. AND SUPPORT
AT THIS TIME PLEASE CONTINUE.
FOR POLITIES- THIS IS THE OR
FORMAT IS A HARD GETTING USED
TO BUT WE ARE DOING WELL
ALRIGHT SO WE WILL NOW SEE IF
THERE ARE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION AND- WE DID NOT HAVE
A FORMAL WE DID NOT HAVE ANY.
SUBMITTING ARE TO BE BLIND. SO
UNLESS MODERATOR THERE'S ANYONE
ON THAT HOST LINE WHICH I DON'T
BELIEVE THERE SHOULD BE. UP TO
SEE IF THERE'S ANYONE IN THIS
HEARING ROOM. THAT WE ARE
PHYSICALLY AND THEN I SEE NINE.
WE WILL NOW LOOK TO THE SECOND
FLOOR HEARING ROOM FOR ANY
OPPOSITION. I SEE NINE SO NOW
WE WILL LOOK TO ANY ONE WHO IS
IN OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL
MIGHT HAVE CALLED IN MODERATOR.
FOR THOSE ON THE PHONE LINES IF
YOU WISH TO VOICE OPPOSITION
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME WE HAVE ONE THAT
IN A LITTLE EARLY I. MIGHT BE A
LATE COMER FOR SUPPORT OR NOT
BUT WE'LL FIND LINE ONE HUH IN
NINETEEN ONE ONE NINE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. THE MORE. REMEMBER
SHERMAN WITH THE RIVER WE
PROMOTE OFF TO THE BILL AND ONE
THANK- A DARK WILL DISPATCH AND
THE LAUNCHERS AND- JUST ONE LET
YOU KNOW THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU. WE HAVE WE HAVE ONE
MORE THAT IS QUEUING UP PLEASE
ALLOW US A MOMENT TO PROVIDE
THEIR LINE FOR CERTAINLY. THANK
YOU WILL GO TO ONE NUMBER
THIRTY SEVEN THREE SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI THIS IS A
BROWN FROM CALIFORNIA COULDN'T
FOCUS SORRY I CAME IN LATE I IN
THE INSTALL- SUPPORT AT THIS
BILL. AND WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE
IN Q. AT THIS TIME PLEASE
CONTINUE. THANK YOU. AND THANK
YOU THOSE YOU CALLING AND I
REALIZE THIS IS A VERY
DIFFERENT WAY BUT WE WILL BE A
PATIENT AND MAKE SURE TO ALLOW
ANYONE. WHO WANTS TO PROVIDE US
TESTIMONY THE ABILITY TO DO SO-
AND SO IF IT TAKES A BIT LONGER
pEVERYONE WHO CALLED IN. AND NOW
ALL SEE IF THERE'S ANY
QUESTIONSFROM ANYONE ON THE
DíAS. A SEEING NINE WE HAVE A
MOTION FOR THE BILL. AND THE
MOTION WOULD BE DO PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS AND SENATOR ALSO
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. EARLY
JULY VOTE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SKIP A THINK IT'S A GOOD BILL I
APPRECIATE THAT THE CALL IN
FROM RIVERSIDE SHERIFF'S AND-
THE WORK THAT YOU'VE DONE WITH-
STAKEHOLDERS IN THIS PROCESS SO
WITH THAT LET'S DO A ROLL CALL
ON THE BOAT WE HAVE A MOTION
AND DISS SB SEVEN ELEVEN. SB
ELEVEN ELEVEN DO PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS SKINNER BY. IN
OUR AYE MORLOCK. OR MORE LIKE
AYE BRADFORD BRADFORD I'D
JACKSON MITCHELL HI MITCHELL
AYE MORALE MORALE NO WINNER OUR
WINNER I. WE WILL LEAVE YOUR
BILL ON CALL FOR OR MISSING
MEMBER- BUT WE WILL NOW GO TO
YOUR NEXT BILL WHICH IS SB
TWELVE NINETY AND I KNOW THAT
WE HAVE TWO WITNESSES WHO WERE
ON THE HOST LINED I KNOW WE
WILL START WITH YOU SENATOR
DRAWS- BUT I'M ONLY GOING TO
SAY THEIR NAMES SO THAT THOSE
WHO ARE. JUST LISTENING TO THIS
YEAR I KNOW THAT WE WILL ONCE
YOU FINISH YOUR PRESENTATION WE
WILL ASK FOR THE HOST LINE TO
BE OPEN AND WE WILL HEAR FROM
ANTHONY ROBLES FROM THE YOUTH
JUSTICE COALITION AND STEPHANIE
COMPAS BOOBY FOR. THE SCHOOL
LAW AND ROOM TO MY FOLKS ON THE
HOST LINE YOUR TOTAL. FOR THE
TWO OF YOU IN TOLL IS MAY GOING
DRAW TWELVE NAY. HUMANITARIAN
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE SB
TWELVE NINETY WILL END THE
HARMFUL AND COSTLY COLLECTION
OF. JUVENILE ADMINISTRATIVE
FEES CHARGED TO YOUTH TWENTY
ONE AND UNDER. IN THE JUVENILE
AND CRIMINAL LEGAL SYSTEMS.
COLLECTING FEES FROM STE SYSTEM
INVOLVED YOUTH AND THEIR
FAMILIES IS REGRESSIVE. FINANCE
AND FINANCIALLY UNSOUND FOR THE
GOVERNMENT TO FUND PUBLIC
SERVICES. AND RESEARCH CHAU
JUVENILE FEES UNDERMINE
REHABILITATION AND INCREASES
RECIDIVISM. IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN
CALIFORNIA ABOLISH THE
IMPOSITION OF SUCH
ADMINISTRATIVE FEES WITH THE BI
PARTISAN PASSAGE OF SENATE BILL
ONE NINETY AUTHORED BY
SENATORS. MITCHELL AND LADA.
THIS INTENSE THIS BILL INTENDS
TO BUILD UPON THAT. SB ONE
NIGHT HE ENDED NEW BE
ASSESSMENTS. SB TWELVE NINETY
WOULD PROHIBIT COUNTIES FROM
COLLECTING FEES ASSESSED PRIOR.
TO JANUARY OF TWENTY EIGHTEEN.
AND REQUIRE COUNTIES TO
DISCHARGE PRIOR FEE AGREEMENTS
CIVIL JUDGMENTS ORLEANS.
ENTERED AGAINST YOUTH FOR THEIR
PARENTS AND GUARDIANS. AT THE
BEGINNING OF THIS YEAR. TWENTY
TWO CALIFORNIA COUNTIES HAVE
CONTINUED TO PURSUE MORE THAN
ONE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS.
FROM FOUR HUNDRED THOUSAND.
ECONOMICALLY VULNERABLE
FAMILIES IN THE STATE. BUT
SINCE THEN ALSO FOR COUNTIES.
RECENTLY TO DISCHARGE FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS. IN OUTSTANDING
JUVENILE FEES REVERSE I'D LAKE.
THAT PLUS. A YET HE SAID OKAY.
THIS BILL WILL ALL PREVIOUS
DISCUSSED FOR ON AND FORCE THE
AND ON ELECTABLE. AND IT WILL
VACATE. ALL COURT JUDGMENTS
STIPULATED AGREEMENTS AND OTHER
INSTRUMENTS IMPOSING SUCH FEES
THE CONTINUED COLLECTION OF
MORE THAN FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS
IN THE REMAINING EIGHTEEN
COUNTIES WOULD BE DEVASTATING
FOR THE YOUTH AND THEIR
FAMILIES. MANY FAMILIES WITH
JUVENILE FEE BILLS WERE IN
PRECARIOUS FINANCIAL SITUATION
BEFORE COVERT NINETEEN. NO
FAMILY SHOULD BE FORCED TO
SACRIFICE OUR HEALTH AND SAFETY
TO MAKE PAYMENTS ON PHASES OF
ALREADY BEEN ABOLISHED BY THE
LEGISLATURE. THANK YOU MEMBERS
FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR AND I URGE AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR
DRAWS SO- LET US JUST CHECK IF
BORROWER AND- A HOST WITNESSES
HER ON THE HOST LINE OUR MAIN
WITNESSES MODERATOR DO WE HAVE
EITHER STEPHANIE COMPOST BROUGH
YEAR ANTHONY ROBLES. WE DO HAVE
ACTUALLY NOW WE JUST GOT
ANTHONY ROBLES ON YOU CAN
PROCEED AND THEN WE'LL FOLLOW
UP WITH STEPHANIE CAMPUS
BREWERY. HELLO MORNING
EVERYBODY THIS ABOUT THE ALL
LIVE WITH THE JUSTICE COALITION%
AND ON THANK YOU FOR HAVING US
HERE TODAY ONLY ABOUT CO
SPONSORS OF AS- NINETY- THIS
BUILD UP OF A BILL THAT WE ALSO
CALL SPONSORED WITH THE LESSON
CENTER MOM POVERTY AT THE ONE
NINETY THAT WILL. GO OUT AND
BUY. BILL AND A LOT OF. ON
WHICH ELIMINATED THE NEW FEES
AND TO GO BACK AND TWENTY BUT
WHERE IN IT WAS VIRTUAL IN THAT
IT LIMóN PAST YOU BUT I THAT
THE FAMILIES GO INTO THOUSAND
NINE HERE LAST COUNTY ON THE-
LIST AND LET IT WITHOUT YOUNG
PEOPLE TO PLACE TO WIN A- I'M
NOT A COUNTY BUT THE PRICE. TO
THAT TO THAT WAS IN THE RACE
WHILE SO. AFTER THE OF SB
NINETY THEIR MOVEMENT TO. BREAK
THE PATH THAT. FOR FAMILIES AND
YOUNG PEOPLE WILL ACQUIRE ON.
BURDEN ABOUT THIS. SO IN
OCTOBER OF TWENTY EIGHTEEN WE
ALONG OUR- A LOCAL CALL.
PARTNER THE LAST YEAR FREE
COLLEGE ONE- MOTION TO. ALL
PASSED YOU BEEN ARE RELATED
THAT- IN LA COUNTY THAT WOULD
WORK NINETY MILLION DOLLARS.
FOR FIFTY TWO THOUSAND FAMILY.
YOU SHOULD. REALLY FOR MANY
FAMILIES ACROSS THE COUNTY ONLY
A LARGE COUNTY. NOW MAN MAN
ACROSS THE STATE LOCAL OTHER
LOCAL COUNTY ELIMINATE THEIR
THE WHERE THE TOLD THAT JUST
YESTERDAY CAN BE ABLE TO VOTED
ELIMINATE THEIR DEBT AND I
THINK THE THAT CROSSES NOW
COULD BE BY MILLION DOLLAR IS A
LOT OF LOCAL I MEAN THERE A LOT
OF WELL YEAH LOW MOMENT. FIVE
NINETY WOULD JUST ON WHAT THE
STATE. IN MY NOT FEES. START
WHILE YEAH I MEAN START WITH
BROTHER HE WITHIN CARD FOR IN
PLACE AND BELIEVE AB AND WE
WERE SHORTLY OF A WE'RE BAKED
ENSURE OUT HOME. AND MY MOM WAS
STOP WITH WITH BILL FOR MY BY
THE CARDS AND I'M ON I. ME TO
WHEN I WAS A YOUNG PERSON I
REQUIRED NOW THAT FROM
CONVICTION THAT I HAD A- THE
JUVENILE COURT ON BY THE I
EIGHTEEN I OR TWO THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN BY AND FEES TO THE
GERMAN COURT AND I COULDN'T
EVEN DRIVE INS. A BILL NOW THE
HUGE BURKE AND. HE WANTED
THINGS- SENATORS THE RAFFLE AND
HOLLY MITCHELL UNLOCKED REDUCE
BILL- AND YEAH I'M NOT FROM
FROM OUTSIDE THE DAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MR ROSE YOU TOOK UP
MOST THE TIME BUT WE WILL ALLOW
MS- BOOT COMPOST TO YOU TO
QUICKLY- AD IN. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY
NAME IS STEPHANIE COMPOST BOY
AND I MISS YOU PROVIDED HER
ATTORNEY IN THE POLICY
ADVOCATES THE CLINIC AT
BERKELEY LAW. WE'RE WE'VE BEEN
RESEARCHING JUVENILE FUSION TWO
THOUSAND THIRTEEN- I RECOGNIZE
I'M SHORT ON TIME SO JUST
QUICKLY SAY I'M IN ADDITION TO
WHAT ANTHONY AND SENATOR ROSS
SO SAD WITH. THAT FORTY
COUNTIES HAVE VOLUNTARILY AT
COLLECTION ON JUVENILE THE-
FOUR WAY TO TAKE AN ACTION
JACKSON THE LAST. LINE OF CODE
NOW CLEAN I'M REALLY LOOKING
KING COUNTY THROUGHOUT. CO ON
ABOUT FOUR THREE NINE DOLLAR.
AND IT'S THE WOULD BRING THOSE
EIGHTEEN COUNTIES INTO LINE
WHAT THE MAJORITY OF COUNTY
HAVE ALREADY DIED. AND REALLY I
FAMILY ALL HEALTH. YEAH I
CANNOT REMOTE A MOTIONAL WORLD.
THESE REGRESSIVE IN RIGHT
LATEST OR IF YOU ON SOFT THERE
AND HAVE. A QUESTION. THANK YOU.
HELLO SEE IF THERE ARE ANY THIS
IS FOR THE HERE IN THIS.
HEARING ROOM INSTANCE THE KNOWN
HAS BEEN A LOCKED IN THE WERE
NO THAN IS ALWAYS BUT IT HERE
SO I'M GOING TO ASSUME THERE'S
NO WITNESSES OF ONE IS WHO ARE
IN THIS FOR PRESENCE AND WE NOW
LOOK AT THE SECOND FOR ROOM IN
THERE. NO THERE SO THE BOOKS
ONE TWO CAN IN SUPPORT OF SB
TWELVE NIGHT FOUR ON THE PHONE
LINE IF YOU'RE NOT YET ON THE
PHONE THIS IS YOUR UP. AND HE
DID CALL. IT YOU MAY. WITNESS
PART. THANK YOU AS REMINDER IT
THE VOICE OF ON THE PHONE YOU
MAY PRESS ONE THEN IT ZERO AT
THIS TIME YOU HAVE NOT DONE.
WILK WITH THE LINEUP ONE THIRD
AND FORTY FOUR ONE FOUR FOR
YOUR MIND IS OPEN. DO YOU MUST.
HAVE A BE HALF THE- EAGLE
COUNTY BORDERS. AND OF THE- ALL
RIGHTS DIEGO YOU WILL GO TO
LINE NUMBER EIGHTY TWO EIGHT TO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MY DOCTOR
OFF ON BEHALF OF THE ACLU OF
CALIFORNIA AND STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. AND LINE NUMBER
SIXTY TWO STICKS TO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. YEAH MEDI HYATT- FOR
THE CALIFORNIA CIVIL LIBERTIES
ADVOCACY IN STRONG SUPPORT. ONE
NINE ONE HUNDRED AND TWENTY TWO
ONE TWO TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING TODD THREATEN ON
BEHALF CENTER FOR RESPONSIBLE
LENDING IN STRONG SUPPORT. LINE
ONE HUNDRED AND FORTY NINE ONE
FOUR NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
OTHER THAN ISSUE DOESN'T STRONG
SUPPORT. FIND SIXTY SIX SIX SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. DARNELL ON
BEHALF OF THE SAN FRANCISCO
PUBLIC DEFENDER'S OFFICE IN
SUPPORT. LINE ONE HUNDRED AND
EIGHT ONE ZERO EIGHT YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING MY NAME
BY GAYLE GARCIA- A. R. T.
POLICY COORDINATOR AND FORMERLY
INCARCERATED YOUTH FROM
RIVERSIDE CALIFORNIA IN STRONG
SUPPORT. LINE ONE HUNDRED AND
FIFTY ONE FIVE ZERO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HI MY NAME'S ALBERT
BUT YOU ARE LEFT WITH THE ANTI
WE SHOULD HAVE BEEN COALITION
IN STRONG SUPPORT YOU'VE BEEN
OUT. OF TOWN. LINE ONE HUNDRED
AND TWO ONE ZERO TO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. THE RADIO WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LINES FOR YOU. LINE
THIRTY THREE THREE THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. BY FAR WITH THE
WESTERN CAROLINE POVERTY
PRACTICE SPONSORING IN SUPPORT
OF THIS LEGISLATION THANK YOU.
LINE ONE HUNDRED AND FIFTY TWO
ONE FIVE TO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
QUICKLY FAVOR ON BEHALF OF
GLIDE IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU. LINE ONE HUNDRED AND FIFTY
THREE ONE FIVE THREE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. BACKING NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER AND MARK.
LINE ONE HUNDRED AND SIXTEEN
ONE ONE SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
AND AREN'T AT THE CENTER ON
JUVENILE AND CRIMINAL JUSTICE
IN SUPPORT. LINE ONE HUNDRED
AND FORTY EIGHT ONE FOUR EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO MY
LAST WITH COMMUNITY WORKS WERE
IN STRONG SUPPORT. LINE ONE
HUNDRED AND THIRTY THREE ONE
THREE THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
SHOULD WE CALDWELL HOUSTON FOR
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION AND REPORT. LINE
ONE HUNDRED AND FORTY SIX ONE
FOUR SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
FIND ONE HUNDRED AND FORTY SIX
CAN YOU CHECK YOUR LINE FOR ME
PLEASE. HEARING NO AUDIO WE
WILL MOVE ON TO LINE ONE
HUNDRED AND SIX ONE ZERO SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO WOULD
YOU TELL ME MORE AS WITH
ANTIMISSILE MOVING COALITION
AND I'M STRONG SUPPORT. ONE
HUNDRED AND THIRTEEN ONE ONE
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. WHAT
IS ANTI RICHARD COLLECTION IN
STRONG SUPPORT. MY NUMBER SIXTY
NINE SIX NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
DOMINIQUE NOTTOTAL DEFENSE
FUND CALIFORNIA IN STRONG
SUPPORT. LINE ONE HUNDRED AND
FIFTY FOUR ONE FIVE FOR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MY NAME IS JACK
WARS AND REPRESENTS ST JOHN'S
WELL JOHN INTENDING CENTER AND
I AM IN SUPPORT OF ITS BIãU
ONE TWO NINE ZERO AND HOLLY
MITCHELL. YOUR LINE HUNDRED AND
FIFTY FIVE ONE FIVE FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GLORIA GONZALEZ.
WELL OF JOHN OF COURSE. FIND
ONE HUNDRED AND FIFTY SEVEN ONE
FIVE SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
YEAH LOW INTERPRETING THE
CALIFORNIA COALITION FOR YOU
REPORT. LINE ONE HUNDRED AND
FIFTY EIGHT TO ONE FIVE EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I COALITION
AND THE STOP COALITION IN
STRONG SUPPORT. LINE ONE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY NINE ONE FIVE
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
COALITION PLEASE AND ALL SHE
POINTS DON'T SUPPORT. AND THAT
DOES EXHAUSTED Q. AT THIS TIME
PLEASE CONTINUE. THANK YOU. WE
DO NOT HAVE I THINK ALREADY
MENTIONED FORMAL OPPOSITION
WITNESSES BUT- DOES THAT ALSO
EXHAUSTED LINE IN TERMS OF-
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION. WE'LL
QUEUE UP FOR PHONE OPPOSITION
ONE AND THEN ZERO THE ONLY
REASON I WENT STRAIGHTTO THE
PHONE LINES IS BECAUSE THERE'S
NO- NO ONE IS IN THIS ROOM. WHO
IS IT CAN BE SEEN AND THE ALSO
NEW ONES IN THE SECOND FLOOR SO
THAT IS WHY I AM ASKING FOR.
PHONE OKAY NOT. YES AND HAVEN'T
BEEN CUTE FOR OPPOSITION THERE
IS NONE. ALL RIGHT- ANY
QUESTIONS FROM THE DíAS
SENATOR MORE LIKE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR. I VOTED
FOR SB ONE NINETY AND I JUST.
OF SOME CONCERNS OF THIS
BECAUSE IT WAS PROSPECT OF A
NOT. A NOT ADDRESS THE PRIOR
BALANCES- SO WE'RE DOWN TO
EITHER. EIGHTEEN OR TWENTY TWO
COUNTIES DEPENDING ON. WHO'S
PROVIDING THE DATA BUT I HAVE.
TWENTY TWO COUNTIES TRYING TO
COLLECT ONE HUNDRED AND THIRTY
SIX MILLION ONE OF THE SPEAKERS
SAID IT'S DOWN TO EIGHTEEN
COUNTIES TRYING TO COLLECT FOR
THREE MILLION. M. O. R.
RECEIVED. MOST OF THE CANCER
JUST UNILATERALLY DECIDED JUST
TO DROP THE WHOLE THING AND- IT
SHOULD BE A LOCAL BOYS. AND SO
THAT'S COMMENDABLE. I'M
CONCERNED ABOUT THOSE THAT ARE
STILL. TRYING TO COLLECT THAT
WERE DRESSING HERE. AND SO I
HAVE DATA OF COUNTYSPENDING
ALMOST AS MUCH AS THE AMOUNT
THEY'RE TRYING TO COLLECT AND I
I'M JUST SORT OF CURIOUS
SENATOR ALSO. HAVE HAVE THESE
COUNTIES SOLD THE RECEIVABLES.
LIKE EIGHTY CENTS THE LADY TOOK
EIGHTY SEND HER CUT JUST SOLD A
TWENTY CENTS AND SO THERE'S A
COMPANY THAT BOUGHT THESE.
ACCOUNTS ARE COLLECTING ON
THEM. I'M JUST SORT OF CURIOUS
WERE. OR IS IT ALL JUST STAFF
DRIVEN WHERE THEY'VE JUST BEEN.
MAKING PHONE CALLS AND SENDING
LETTERS. THE CENTER MORE LIKE I
AM NOT SURE OF THE ANSWER I
JUST KNOW THAT THE END RESULT
IS THAT IT'S NOT WORTH THE TIME
AND THE MONEY THAT'S BEING
SPENT TO TRY TO COLLECT UP ON
IT IT'S JUST THAT IT'S NOT
WORTH IT SO I DON'T SPECIFICS
I. ANY OF. IF SEVEN COMBOS
MOVIE WOULD YOU HAVE ANY MORE
INFORMATION ABOUT THE. YEAH
SURE AND SO MOST OF THIS THAT
ARE ACTUALLY ALL THE FAT IS NOT
SENT TO PRIVATE COLLECT
AGENCIES IT'S ALL THE WAY STAND
THAT COUNTY REVENUE DEPARTMENTS
THAT YOU CALL CAN. I THAT SHOW
THAT'S WHY WHEN YOU SEE YOU
ORANGE FOR EXAMPLE IS SPENDING
AND EIGHTY CENTS ON THE- THEIR
SPENDING AND THAT MY MONEY ON
STAFF. TRYING TO COLLECT MONEY
AND GET PROCEED AS- I THAT KIND
OF WHAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT AND
YEAH THE UPDATED NUMBER. IN
EIGHTEEN COUNTY THE FORTY THREE
NOT AND I WILL SAY. 85% OF THAT
IS HELD BY ORANGE AND TULARE
COUNTY. MORE THAN THAT SINCE
OUR REPRESENT ORANGE COUNTY
LIVING. NOT DEFENDED BUT LET ME
ASK YOU ABOUT IT IF THEY'RE
SPENDING EIGHTY TWO CENTS. ON
THE DOLLAR THEY'RE GIVING OUR
LEAVING EIGHTEEN CENTS ON THE
TABLE BY NOT PURSUING- THE
AMOUNT OF. THESE BILL'S ARM
WOULD THAT BE THEN A ARE A
REIMBURSABLE MANDATE WHERE THEY
COULD APPLY TO THE STATE AND
SAY HEY GIVE US EIGHTEEN CENTS
ON. WE'RE I DON'T THINK SO.
THERE IS ANYBODY WHO HAS A MORE
MORE LEGAL ANSWER TO THAT. IF
YOU DON'T MIND CENTER MORE
WATER WILL CALL IN SENATOR
MITCHELL'S CARRIED A BILL AND
SHE MAY HOUSES SUBJECT MATTER
EXPERT BRED SENATOR MITCHELL
THANK YOU SENATOR MORLOCK- I
DON'T KNOW ABOUT ALL THAT BUT I
DID SPEND QUITE A BIT OF TIME
ON THE ISSUE WITH SOME OF THE
FOLKS ON THE PHONE. WHAT I'D
SAY ON SEVERAL GO MOST TROUBLE
THAT MANY OF THE COUNTIES THAT
CARRIED THE- BOMB- HIGHEST DEAD
IF YOU WILL WE'RE ALSO COUNTIES
THAT WEREN'T FOLLOWING CURRENT
LAW AT THAT TIME AND WE'RE
PURSUING PEOPLE WHO CURRENT LAW
WAVED FIND. ARM AND SOUL- I
DON'T REMEMBER ORANGE COUNTY
SPECIFICALLY IF THEY WERE ALL
QUITE FRANKLY ONE OF THE
OFFENDERS BUT THAT WAS WHAT WE
FOUND MOST TROUBLING THAT
PEOPLE WERE ALREADY BEING
FINED- YOU KNOW. GIVEN GIVEN.
COVER UNDER CURRENT LAW THAT
SAID IF YOU WERE LOW INCOME AND
THAT CERTAIN CRITERIA THAT YOU
SHOULD BE WAVE CHARACTER
PURSUING EVERYBODY ON. I
APPRECIATE YOUR PERSPECTIVE
THAT IF THE STATE MANDATE SAYS
THAT WE ELIMINATE FINES AND
FEES BUT THAT'S NOT THE
PRACTICE THAT. IN THE COUNTY
SEVEN GATE A GOOD NUMBER OF
COUNTIES HAD VOLUNTARILY STOP
THE PRACTICE BEFORE WE EVEN
INTRODUCED THE BILL TWO YEARS
AGO BECAUSE THEY FOUND THAT
VERTICALLY WITH WITH REGARD TO
JUVENILES IT WAS COUPLE IN
THEIR ABILITY TO REUNITE WITH
THEIR FAMILIES AND ALL JUVENILE
LOCKED TALKS ABOUT THE WHOLE
POINT IS TO REUNIFY AN
IMPROVISED AT THE PORT OF
OPPORTUNITY FOR THE- FAMILIES.
RESEARCH SHOWED UP AND- WERE
COMPLICATED. I AGREE TO YOUR
BILL. AND SO THAT'S RAIMES TO
GET OKAY FINE STOP IT YOU KNOW
IT'S NOT WORKING FOR A GOOD
NUMBER OF REASONS. BUT WE
DIDN'T MAKE IT RETROACTIVE SOON
ITS ANOTHER SISTER RECEIVABLE
ON THE BOOKS WRITTEN. HARD TO
COLLECT IN. MOST MANAGERS SO
SAID LET'S NOT SPENDING MORE
MONEY ON THIS BECAUSE IT'S NOT
WORTH THE TIME AND SENATE
CLAIRE'S CASE. SPENDING MORE
THAN THEY'RE RECEIVING SO THAT
ALL MAKES SENSE BUT- FOR THOSE
COUNTIES THAT SOMEHOW HAVEN'T
COME TO THAT CONCLUSION WE'RE
NOW UNILATERALLY SAYING TO A
LOCAL BODY. YOU WILL. RIGHT OFF
YOUR RECEIVABLES. END OF
DISCUSSION. AND I'M I'M
WONDERING WHY SHOULD WE DO THAT
TO A LOCAL AGENCY. WHEN THEY
CAN DO IT ON THE ROAD. AN
THROUGH THE CHAIR YOU MAY
ANSWER MITCHELL. SORRYSENATOR
ALTHOUGH. HE WAS LOOKING AT ME
THAT'S WHY I LEAN BACK IN I HE
RIGHT I SEE YOU BUT YOU KNOW
AND THIS WOULD HAVE BEEN OUR
DESIRE IN THE ORIGINAL BILL-
BUT WE WERE CLEAR THAT WE WERE-
FOLLOWING THE NATIONAL BRAND
AND WANTED TO STOP COLLECTION
FROM POINT AND THE GOLD EXTRA
STEP. WHICH UP. COUNTIES THAT
HAVE NOW COME ON. FAQ ANNUAL
ALSO WORK THAT YOU KNOW THE
COUNTIES BEGIN TO COOK BEGAN
COLLECTING THESE FINES AND FEES
DURING A TIME WHEN THERE
BUDGETS WERE REDUCED- AS A
RESULT OF STATE CUT BACKS AND
SO IT BECAME. A EIGHT HM ISSUE
AS OPPOSED TO WHETHER IT REALLY
IS FOR THE MILLIE THE RIGHT
THING TO DO AND SELL ONLY
INTRODUCED A BILL AND SEVENTEEN
IT WAS DURING A TIME WHEN-
LOCAL COFFERS WERE CERTAINLY
MORE FLOOD NAY HAD BEEN IN THE
PREVIOUS TEN YEARS. A AGAIN
LOOKING AT THE RESEARCH.
PROPONENTS ON THE PHONE
RECOGNIZING HOW MANY COUNTIES
WERE ON COLLECTING UNDER
CURRENT LAW INAPPROPRIATELY AND
THAT WAS THE REAL PUSH. AND SO
I HEAR WHAT YOU'RE SAYING IS
WHETHER NOTS IT'S APPROPRIATE
TO FORCE COUNTIES TO NOT
COLLECTED A RECEIVABLE ON I
GUESS THAT'S JUST YOU KNOW THE
MATTER OPINION ON THEY THERE'S
RESEARCH THAT SUGGESTED IT WAS
AND PROBABLY AN INAPPROPRIATE
ACTION TO TAKE IN THE FIRST
PLACE. TO BE PERFECTLY HONEST I
AM AND WE WILL. AT BUT IT WAS
OF THE LAW AND SO THEY DID WHAT
THEY WERE SUPPOSED TO DO AND-
AND SO NOW I JUST WONDER IF
THERE'S A WAY TO SPLIT THE BABY
LIKE. WE'LL GIVE YOU TO FOR THE
REMAINING QUE. TEN CENTS ON THE
DOLLAR. AS OPPOSED TO JUST
TAKING IT ALL AWAY- AND THAT'S
JUST THAT'S WHERE I'M HAVING.
MAYBE THE BUSINESS HANGOVER BUT
ALL THAT. AND AGAIN I WANT TO
SAY THAT AT THE STATE LEVEL YOU
KNOW IT WASN'T A STATE. LAW
THAT. MANDATED THAT THEY
COLLECT THE FINES AND FEES IN
THE FIRST PLACE. THOSE ARE
DECISIONS MADE AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL. BUT WHAT IS IF THEY FOR.
COLLECTING FINES AND FEES.
BECAUSE THE STATE. REQUIRED
THAT THEY DO SO. NOT BUT NOW
IT'S STATE COMING IN SAYING
ROOM THOSE LAWS. SO WITH THE
JUST SORT OF A UNIQUE.
SITUATION OF SACRAMENTO VERSUS
LOCAL AND I'M JUST TRYING TO
FIND YOUR AVAILABLE. CENTER
MORE LIKE YOU YOU MAYES IF
THERE'S ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS TO
THE AUTHOR YOU MAY BUT IN THE
MEANTIME I AM TRYING TO GET AN
ANSWER TO THE SPECIFIC QUESTION
OF WHETHER THIS BILL. AND HOW
IT IS CONSTRUCTED AS SENATOR TO
THERE HAS PRESENTED. WHETHER
THAT CREATES A STATE
REIMBURSABLE MANDATE OKAY SO
I'M TRYING TO GET THAT ANSWER
FOR YOU AND WILL- I DON'T THINK
IT DOES- THE- BUT I AM TRYING
TO GET THAT ANSWER OKAY. SO SIR
MARK HAVE ADDITIONAL QUESTION
TO THE AUTHOR NO I DO NOT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH OF A AND E'S
CENTER DRUGS SO LIKE I
INDICATED AYE AYE THE- THIS
DOES NOT SHOW AND I DO THINK
THAT THIS THE ACTION. THIS BILL
TAKES CREATES A I DO NOT THINK
IT CREATES A REIMBURSABLE MANDY
BUT I AM TRYING TO GET- THE
ACTUAL ANSWER TO THAT ALL
RIGHT. MADAM CHAIR JUST WANNA
THANK YOU THAT WITH THE SOCIAL
SYNCING I AT LEAST HAD A CHANCE
TO TALK TO SENATOR MITCHELL
KNELT. SEE THERE'S ANYONE OUT
THE DOOR AS WELL AS A QUESTION
WHILE WE ARE. WE ARE WAITING
FOR THAT. AND THEN SEEING NINE
SENATOR ALSO WILL ALLOW YOU TO
CLOSE I MAKE IT A TEXT WITH THE
ANSWERING BETWEEN. OKAY WELL I
ESPECIALLY WANT TO THANK
SENATOR MITCHELL FOR ALL THE
WORK THAT SHE DID PRIOR TO THIS
AND FOR BEING WATER AND SENATOR
WIENER ALSO FOR BEING CO
AUTHORS- WE SHOULD. WE SHOULD
JUST DEAL WITH THESE DEBTS ON
COLLECTIBLE THEY'RE CAUSING
ENORMOUS STRESS AND MANY MANY
PROBLEMS FOR THOSE FAMILIES
AND- I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR IN
MY BOOK. AND GREATER JUST AN
ANSWER IT WOULD APPEAR THAT
LEDGE COUNCIL INDICATES THAT
THIS IS NOT- DOES NOT CREATE A
REIMBURSABLE MANDATE. ALL RIGHT
SIR- DO WE DID GET A MOTION TO
RIGHT. OR DID I OKAY SIR WE
HAVE A MOTION. AND THE MOTION
IS- DO PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS
LET'S CALL THE ROLL. DO PASSED
TO APPROPRIATIONS SB TWELVE
NINETY SKINNER. BY IN OUR AYE
MORE LARK. BRAD BIRD ALL RIGHT
BRADFORD AYE JACKSON BY FAX AND
I MITCHELL BY THE JULY MORALE.
WELL NO WIENER. LIKE WIENER HI.
ARE YOUR BILL IS OUT ITS FIVE
ONE I DON'T BELIEVE I HAVE TO
HOLD THE RULE OPENED SO. GOOD
WE CAN ROLL ON LEAST ONE
FINALLY CLOSE RULE IN A COUPLE
HOURS I THINK SO. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH SENATOR DRESSER WILL
NOW TURN TO OUR LAST STOP
TURNER CLASS BILL SB ELEVEN
THIRTY THREE SENATOR JACKSON
WHICH YOU CAN DO RIGHT FROM THE
DíAS AND- THE- PORT WHERE. IS
YOUR ON THE POST. OUR CHURCH
KEVIN BRIZILL. AND BELOW ARE AT
MICHAEL BLOW WILL BE IN PERSON
NOT ON THE LINE BUT- GO AHEAD
SENATOR JACKSON'S. PRESENT
THANK YOU OF MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I APPRECIATE THE
INDULGENCE TO ALLOW TO GO LET.
OUR THIS MEASURE POSTPONES THE
SUNSET DATE ON A LAW THAT
REDUCES THE NUMBER OF
PEREMPTORY CHALLENGES AFFORDED
IN MISDEMEANOR MISDEMEANOR
TRIALS. I WILL BE ACCEPTING THE
AMENDMENTS THAT POSTPONED THE
SUN SETTING OF EXISTING LAW FOR
PERIOD OF THREE YEARS. NOW IN A
CRIMINAL TRIALBOTH THE
PROSECUTOR AND DEFENSE ATTORNEY
ARE PERMITTED TO CHALLENGE
JURORS THAT THEY BELIEVE TO BE
UNFIT TO SERVE THESE CHALLENGES
MAY EITHER BE FOR CAUSE OR
CHOSE ROOM THREE CHALLENGES. IN
A FOR CAUSE CHALLENGE THE IT IS
QUESTION POTENTIAL JURORS TO
ELICIT ENOUGH INFORMATION TO
CONVINCE THE JUDGE THAT A JUROR
IS NOT QUE OF RENDERING AN
IMPARTIAL VERDICT. OBSERVE LATE
THE JUDGE MRS. THAT THE DOES
NOT GO AGAINST PEREMPTORY
CHALLENGES STILL AVAILABLE ON
THE BASIS OF JUST SIMPLY A
DECISION THAT YOU DON'T LIKE.
THE LOOK THE ANSWER YOU STILL
ARE ENTITLED TO REMOVAL FOR
PEREMPTORY CHALLENGES THAT ARE
NOT AT THE EXPENSE. IN ANY WAY
OF THE CAR FOR A PRINTER
CHALLENGE SO. ARE AGAIN AN
ATTORNEY CAN SIMPLY DISMISS IT.
AJ PEREMPTORILY WITHOUT GIVING
ANY. TO SEE. IN MISDEMEANOR
TRIALS AGAIN NOT TOUCHING OF
DISMISSAL FOR COSTS SO THIS
NUMBER OF SIX IN MISDEMEANOR
TRIALS HAS BEEN THE LAW FOR
JUST OVER THREE YEARS PRIOR TO
THAT THE CAP ON THE PEREMPTORY
CHALLENGE NUMBER WAS TEN. THE
LAW OF THE REDUCES THE NUMBER
OF PEREMPTORIES IN THESE CASES
FROM STAND TO SIX IS DUE TO
SUNSET JANUARY OF JANUARY FIRST
OF NEXT YEAR. NOT THE SUNSET
DATING TENSION CONTAINED IN
THIS MEASURE ELEVEN THIRTY
THREE THE NUMBER OF
PEREMPTORIES WILL RETURN TO THE
YES RULE OF TEN FOR MISDEMEANOR.
WITH GREAT THAN THE DAYS AND-
OF FOUR MISDEMEANORS WITH
PENALTIES OF NINETY DAYS OR
LESS. AS YOU WILL HEAR FROM LOS
ANGELES SUPERIOR COURT
PRESIDING JUDGE KEVIN BRAZIL.
OUR JUDGES FEEL VERY STRONGLY
THAT THE REDUCED NUMBER OF
PEREMPTORY CHALLENGES RESULT IN
MORE EFFICIENT CORD
ADMINISTRATION WITH NO
DIMINUTION OF THE RIGHTS OF
CRIMINAL DEFENDANTS. COURTED
ASIAN IS MORE FISH AS YOU WERE
JUROR. WANT TO SERVE IN A- WHEN
NUMBER OF PEREMPTORY CHALLENGES
DECREASES. INDEED IN A STUDY BY
THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL. HE FOUND
THE 6% DECREASE IN THE NUMBER
OF JURORS CALLED SINCE THE
NUMBER OF PEREMPTORY WAS
REDUCED. THAT 6% OUT TO BE
TENTH. CITIES WHO DO NOT NEED
TO BE CALLED FOR JURY THE- EVEN
TODAY PARMON SO. DISTANCE IT IS
LAW THE COURTS WILL HAVE.
GETTING POTENTIAL- STEVEN
REPORT FOR SERVICE ADDITIONALLY
THE FEWER PROSPECTIVE JURORS
THERE ARE THE CITY. ROOMS WILL
ADMINISTRATION OF OUR JURY
SYSTEM THIS IN LIGHT AND THE
TREMENDOUS BACKLOG IN TRIAL
THAT WE HAVE IN THE COURTS. OR
THE COLD TEEN SITUATION. THIS
WHOLE STUDY WHEN THE PEREMPTORY
LIMIT WAS SET AT TEN AND I
THINK THIS IS INTERESTING TO
NOTE THE AVERAGE NUMBER OF
PEREMPTORIES. WITH HER THAN SIX
BY EACH ATTORNEY AND THE
MAXIMUM WAS REDUCED TO SIX THE
AVERAGE DROPPED OF FOR THE
DEFENSE ATTORNEYS WERE RARELY
USING MORE THAN THE SIX TO
WHICH WERE ENTITLED NO BY THE
WAY. VERY IMPORTANT. IN ANY WAY
FIVE WAR CAN. TURN ANY OTHER IN.
THAT THE REDUCED NUMBER OF
PEREMPTORIES IS DAMAGING TO
CRIMINAL DEFENDANTS I BELIEVE
REDUCING THE NUMBER OF
PEREMPTORY CHALLENGES WILL
IMPROVE JUDICIAL ADMINISTRATION
AND REDUCE IT IS RESISTANCE TO
JURY SERVICE WELL HAVING NO
EFFECT ON THE RIGHTS OF
CRIMINAL DEFENSE. AT THE
MENTIONED. ON THE LINE. OF
MISTER OF BELOW HERE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF THIS MISSION. OUR
MODERATOR YOU CAN ALLOW A JUDGE
BRAZIL ON THE HOST LINE TO.
TESTIFY SELL YOUR LINE IS OPEN
YOU MAY PROCEED THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE
THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO
SPEAK TO YOU TODAY AND I AM
JUDGE KEVIN SIEVERS THOUGH THE
PRESIDING JUDGE. YOUR WORK. THE
COURT CLOSURES AROUND STATE DO
TO COPE NINETEEN WHICH IN MARCH
VIRTUALLY NO TRIAL COURT IN THE
STATE HAVE BEEN ABLE TO CONDUCT
CRIMINAL JURY TRIALS. THIRTY OR
FIFTY EIGHT FULLY REOPEN LATER
THIS MONTH AND AROUND THE
SUMMER MONTHS THERE WILL BE
THOUSANDS OF MISTER CASES TO BE.
FOR EXAMPLE IN LOS ANGELES
COUNTY WHICH IS THE LARGEST
TRIAL COURT IN THE NATION BUT
NEARLY SIX HUNDRED OPERATIONAL
COURTROOM. THERE WILL BE OVER
ONE THOUSAND MISDEMEANOR CASES
THAT WILL NEED TO BE TRIED
WITHIN THE FIRST TWO WEEKS OF
MY COURT JUNE TWENTY SEVEN. DAY
TO BE OPEN. I ABOUT TWELVE
THOUSAND YOUR- A CORD OUT
LOCATED IN- IN LOS ANGELES
COUNTY. DECENT PRINTER
CHALLENGES FROM TEN TO SIX IT
IS ESTIMATED THAT WE WILL
SOMEONE ABOUT THREE THOUSAND
FEWER JURORS EACH DAY IN LOS
ANGELES. IS EXTREMELY DIFFICULT
FOR MOST COURTROOMS IN LOS
ANGELES COUNTY TO MAINTAIN
SOCIAL DISTANCING WHEN A LARGE
NUMBER HERE'S OUR PRESIDENT.
MAINTAINING SIX ENTRY CHAT
TRIALS IS ONE COMMONSENSE
PROPOSAL BACK IN BENEFIT JURORS
AND OUR COMMUNITY BY HELPING TO
REDUCE THE SPREAD OF COVERT
NINETEEN. MOST STATES GIVE EACH
EIGHT THREE PEREMPTORY
CHALLENGES FOR MISDEMEANOR
CASES. THE PASSAGE OF SB EIGHT
FORTY THREE AND TWENTY SIXTEEN
NO CONVICTION HAS BEEN REVERSED
AND STATE DUE TO THE DEFENDANT
NOT HAVING ENOUGH. THIS BUDGET
HOW TO OF THE RIGHT TO A FAIR
TRIAL ISN'T WRONG BECAUSE
TWELVE PERSON NAM FOR IS STILL.
IN YOUR IS CAN BE. WITHOUT
LIMITATION FOR BECAUSE THAT'S
HIS BIAS OR PREJUDICE. YEAH I
JUST HAVE ALWAYS BEEN AT THE
FOREFRONT OF SAFEGUARDING AND
PROVIDING A GUARANTEE OF A
DEFENSE SIX AMENDMENT RIGHT TO
A FAIR AND IMPARTIAL JURY. THE
ELEVEN THIRTY THREE DOESN'T
SEEM TO AFFECT. THIS RIGHT FOR
GUARANTEED. YOUR WILL EXTEND
THE SUNSET BACK THREE YEARS
THEREBY MAINTAINING SONOMA TO
ASSIST THE COURTS AS WE
NAVIGATE GROUP COVERT NINETEEN
CRISIS. AND WILL CONTINUE TO
ENSURE DEFENDANT'S RIGHT TO A
FAIR TRIAL. FOR THESE REASONS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR VOTE IN
SUPPORT OF SB UPCOMING THIRTY
THREE. THANK YOU SO VERY MUCH
TIME AND FOR ALLOWING ME TO
SPEAK I WOULD BE HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU I.
MR BELOW THANK YOU ARE ALSO
WITNESS GO AHEAD MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS MICHAEL BUT ON
BEHALF CALIFORNIA JUDGES IS A-
PRIVILEGE FOR JUDGES FOR THIRTY
YEARS. I HAVE BEEN HONORED
WATCH THEM WORK FOR THE FAIR
ADMINISTRATION OF JUSTICE FOR
THAT ENTIRE TIME I'VE BEEN
ASKED WHY IS IT MEDICAL ISSUE
THIS YEAR AND THE JUDGE.
EXPLAINED IT BUT THAT
EXPERIENCE IS REPLICATED ALL
OVER THE STATE EVEN BEFORE COLD
AND WE HAD A FULLY HALF. HELLO
AND- EVERY EVERY REASON TO
EXPECT THAT DIFFICULTY TO GET
WORSE NOT BETTER BUT YOU HAVE A
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT THE TRIAL
IN CALIFORNIA IN BOTH CRIMINAL
AND COUNTERS EDIT SEE TO ME
THAT AS WE HEAD INTO THIS
COVERED UP AND IT COULD LAST
WHILE. BE OF THE CORE. THIS
RESOURCES. MIDDLE DEFENDANTS
AND FOR CIVIL LITIGANTS SO WE
WOULD ASK RESPECTFULLY THAT WE
BE GIVEN THREE YEARS TO
EFFECTUATE THE LAW AND WE'RE TO
TALK ABOUT THE ISSUE OF
PEREMPTORY CHALLENGES IN A MORE.
HAPPY AND WILLING TO ENGAGE IN
THAT DISCUSSION WE WENT FOR AND
I HAVE A THANK YOU THANK YOU
MISTER MILLER- SO WE WELL NOW I
CAN ALREADY SEE THERE ARE NO
WITNESSES IN THE ROOM FOR THE-
ROOMS SO THOSE. ARE THE WHO
WANT TO FOR IN SO OF THIS ON
THE TELL. GET YOURSELF READY
SECOND FLOOR CONFERENCE ROOM
GIVE ME A SCREEN SHOT I THINK
IT'S STILL EMPTY BUT LET'S GET
STILL EMPTY SO. THIS ONE-
MODERATOR. YOU CAN THE PHONE
LINE FOR THE WAY INSERT OF A-
THAT. ELEVEN THIRTY SENATOR
JACKSON'S. THANK YOU ONCE AGAIN
IF YOU'D LIKE TO VOICE SUPPORT
ON THE PHONE LINES YOU MAY
PRESS AND THEN IT ZERO AT THIS
TIME BREAKDOWN OF. WE WILL GO
TO A NUMBER FORTY SIX FOUR.
YOUR LINE IS. MORNING MADAM SHE
COMMITTEE MEMBER I'M GAY
STEWART HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
SAN DIEGO TO ATTORNEY SUMMER
STEP IN WE ARE PORT OF SENATE
BILL ELEVEN THIRTY AND THANK.
JACKSON YOUR AYE THAT THANK YOU.
YOU WILL TO LAW HUNDRED SIXTY
ONE SIX FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
ALL THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY
NAME IS KEN MCGILL WITH THESE
JUSTICE COALITION FOR ALL TOLD
FOR THE BILL SENATE BILL ONE
THIRTY THREE. I'M ALSO WOULD
TRY TO. TESTIFIED EARLIER WERE
ALSO FULL OR- SEVEN TWELVE
NINETY WHEN WE ELIMINATE YOU
LITTLE TO IN LA. NINETEEN
DOLLARS JUST IN A COUNSELING.
TO THANK YOU FOR. THANK YOU
WILL GO TO LINE ONE AND FIVE
ONE SIX ONE IS OPEN. JUDGE
JONES FROM THE SAN DIEGO
SUPERIOR COURT. FORMER PRESS OF
THE CAL JUDGE HAVE. I STRONGLY
SUPPORT HELLO. THIRTY THREE.
THANK YOU WILL GO TO LINE UP
LINE IS. THANK THIS IS SHERIN
RIGHT. THE COUNCIL AND WE ARE
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE CELL
AND THINK. SENATOR DR KERRY NOT.
THANK YOU WILL GET A LINE ONE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY SIX ONE FIVE
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ONE ONE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY SIX HAS
DROPPED ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
WE'LL GO TO LINE ONE HUNDRED
AND FIFTY FIVE ONE FIVE FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MORNING
EVERYONE A GLORIA GONZALEZ WITH
THESE JUST. A JOB. AND WITH
THAT WE HAVE EXHAUSTED THE
QUEUE YOU MAY CONTINUE. SO WE
NOW WILL GO TO OPPOSITION
WITNESSES I BELIEVE ON THE HOST
LINE WE HAVE TO OPPOSITION
WITNESSES IGNACIO HERNANDEZ.
AND LESLIE CALDWELL HOUSTON
MODERATOR OPPOSITION WITNESSES
IN IN TOTALLY THE WITNESSES
HAVE IN THREE MINUTES. FIND
OPEN. SEAT THANK YOU THIS IS
THE LAW CALL HUGHES FOR THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC ASSOCIATION
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
COMMITTEE MEMBER SENATORS WITH
RESPECT WE HAVE TO DECLARE THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS. IF
YOU CAN VEHEMENTLY OPPOSE TO BE
ELEVEN THIRTY THREE THE ABILITY
OF A CRIMINAL DEFENSE ATTORNEY
TO ENSURE THAT HER CLIENT THE-
BY. CAREFUL JURY SELECTION HOW
DO THE ELEVEN THIRTY THREE
EXTENDING READOUT IN GRAY
CHALLENGES ATTACKS THAT THE OF
JUROR YOU SEARCH THE TO CHOOSE
I'M BY. WORK GEN THREE OVER DUE
PROCESS. MY INNER WITH LET THE
DISH ATTORNEY WORK AT CRITICAL
OF THE- JUDGE AND THE LAWYERS
DIFFERENTLY. FIND YOUR CONTRARY
TO JUDGES TESTING YOU CAN GET
IN THAT RIVER BASED ON LAW. AND
CONTRARY TO THE SENATOR UP OUR
STATEMENT IT REALLY IS NOPE TO
MAKE A COMPLAINT. WE MAY BOTH
COMPLAINT BEFORE. THIS WHY
WOULD YOU CAN. AND MAY LOG
BEFORE THE WERE CONSIDERED AND
NOT TASK. THE REASON AYE
WORKING ENDED DEFENSE FOR
NEARLY THIRTY YEARS WAS BECAUSE
OF MY RESPECT FOR THE TO OF THE
STATES AND CAL. THE SIXTH
AMENDMENT RAINING SHOULD BE
DEEPER ETCHED ALL WE DO IN OUR
ROOM THE RIGHT TO TRIAL BEARING
IN PART JUROR IS A GOOD THING.
THE. THANK OR CONCERN ARE WITH
THE. HI I'M XIN IT DOES NOT
FRUSTRATE DO WITH IN MEANT
THREE PDA IS JUST BY A BY THE
COR THE WORK LOAD SHOULD BE
WERE ON THE BACK OF PEOPLE BY
THE STATE. CHARGE EACH CHARGE
COULD CARRY A YEAR IN CUSTODY
LEADING TO MULTIPLE YEARS THE
CRIMINAL RECORD COME WITH A
MISDEMEANOR CONVICTION HERE
MARION COLLATERAL CON. NONE OF
THIS IS MY TO THOSE WHO
BASEMENT CHARGES. COMPLAIN DID
YOU CAL DOES NOT SUPPORT THE
CLAIM. THAT REDUCE THE NUMBER
OF PEREMPTORY WILL MAKE TRIALS
TRYING TO. LESS BURKE. OR LEFT
HI COSTLY WHAT DO REPORT STATE
WAS THAT IN SESSION TIME WHEN
UP SLIGHTLY POSSIBLY DO TO MORE.
CASES BEING HEARD AFTER FORTY
SEVEN RIDGE I'M TELLING YOU A
SYSTEM. THE FACT THAT MORE
LOCATED CASES FOR SEVEN AND.
THE TRIAL IS A STRONG. POINT TO
TEN I'M VERY CHALLENGE.
ACCORDING TO THE OVER DID IN
TOTAL SIZE IT WAS NAY LEADING
TO KNOW REAL REDUCTION THE
REPORT ALSO STATES THAT THE
REDUCTION CRAMPED CHALLENGES
WAS IN. AND IT IS DIFFICULT TO
SAY THE RE. IN A LAB GRAHAM
JURY MAY ANY DE. SAID THAT
CRIMINAL TRIALS REPRESENT OUT
EDGE OF RESOURCE USE BY THE
CALL. YOUR I'M TAKING ALL OF
THE CASHIERS TIED UP TO THREE
MINUTES OR NOW UP THE THREE
MINUTES ARE UP. I'M SORRY CAN
YOU HAVE A FEW MINUTES ACTUALLY.
NOT. SHE. BECAUSE WE HAVE A LOT
OF NOTES HERE WILL GIVE YOU
THIRTY FIVE SECONDS OKAY GO
AHEAD MADAM CHAIR YES I'M SURE
THAT THE- BUT OUT OF ALL DUE
RESPECT PRIOR WITNESSES I
ACTUALLY FIND IN TOGETHER THEIR
TESTIMONY WITH ABOUT. I'M A
QUICKLY LAST YEAR. TIME ONE
MINUTE. SO I SPENT TEN YEAR
SORRY NOT HERNANDEZ ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA TERMS FOR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE OKAY WHAT
SINCE USE YOUR COMON SENSE. I
SPENT TEN YEARS. PROPOSAL THE
NUMBER CHALLENGES BECAUSE- NO
BENEFIT TO PEOPLE HER AGE OF
CRIMES IS. BODY IN TRYING TO
REFORM THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE. TO
INCREASE THE EARNING. BETTER
OUTCOMES MORE. AND WE REDUCING
CRIME FREE CHALLENGES BECAUSE
THE OPPOSITE WAY IT MAKES IT
MORE CHALLENGING TO GET IT
SOONER JERRY YOU GET
REPRESENTATIVE JERRY.
ABSOLUTELY NO. TO THOSE ARE
AFTER PARTY TO THE MEDICATION.
OTHER WAYS TO CHEAT YOU SHOULD
CHANGE. IN CALLING A CALL IF
YOU WERE WE HAVE CALLED FOR
THAT PERTAIN YEARS THE OTHER
ISSUES THAT JUDGES CONTROL
QUESTION. IF THEY WANT TO. ONE
CONTROL ARE IN CHARGE AND
BECAUSE OF THAT THE STATE'S
ATTORNEY DON'T HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY ASK THE QUESTION
ONE ASK ALL OF THE TIME ON THE
JUDGE SHOULD GIVE THEM ENOUGH
TIME TO STOP BY WE NEED TO
PRINT WHICH- JUST. FOUR YEAR.
WE HAVE TO BE JUST GO TO THE IT
ON THE REASON WHY CHANGE A
START TO THE BUDGET BILL A FEW
YEARS AGO AND THE STATE ONCE
REQUIRE. THEY ARE THANK NOT.
I'M SURE THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT
WE WILL.SEE IF THERE ARE
ADDITIONAL OPPOSITION ON THE
PHONE LINES- MODERATOR. YOU CAN
OPEN THOSE LINES WHICH IS
ALWAYS OPPOSITION ON THE PHONE
YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
TIME WILL GO TO A LOT NUMBER
SIXTY TWO. TO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
YES AS A MATTER HIGHER
CALIFORNIA CIVIL LIBERTIES
ADVOCACY IN STRONG OPPOSITION-
PEOPLE OVERCOMING. THANK YOU
FOR GOOD OLD FIND ONE IN
SEVENTY ONE I DON'T WANNA
UNDERLINE IS OPEN. I WILL BE
GLAD TO OPPOSE. THE PEOPLE
ECONOMY. THANK YOU LINE SIXTY
SIX SIX SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
PANICLE MY MOM BEHALF OF THE
CAMP AND THE PUBLIC DEFENDER'S
OFFICE RESPECTFULLY IN
OPPOSITION. AND LINE ONE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY FIVE ONE FIVE
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. AGAIN
GLORIA WITH THE YOUTH JUSTICE
COALITION AND I WAS CONFUSED
ABOUT- I KNOW. THAT NAY GROUND
ABOUT BUDGET. THANK YOU FOR THE
CLARIFICATION WHEN. THANK YOU
THAT DOES EXULTED EXHAUST THE
PHONE QUEUE AT THIS TIME PLEASE
PENA SO THERE'S NO PHONE QUEUE
IN TERMS OF PEOPLE WHO MAY HAVE
WANTED TO. PRESS SUPPORT WHO
MAY NOT HAVE IT ON. GOT ON
FINISH THERE'S NOBODY THERE'S
NO ONE IN THE QUEUE AT ALL AT
THIS TIME THANK YOU. AND LET'S
SEE IF THE- IT'S FOR OUR AUTHOR
DíAS. HAD SENT A RICH YOUR
COMMENTS GO AHEAD APPRECIATE
THAT I DON'T HAVE A QUESTION I
JUST CONVERSATION WITH THE- AND
I. MUST ACKNOWLEDGE UPDATE IT
NOT TO IS ABSOLUTELY RIGHT IT
WAS DROPPED IN THE BUDGET BILL
I IN THE- TENTH OUR SERVER IS
AGO WHICH IS HOW WE- GOT TO
WHERE WE WERE- IT WAS IT. LATE
COULDN'T GET THROUGH AND- THE
SENATE CHOSE TO ACCEPT THAT AND
SO I THINK IT THAT. YOU KNOW
CURRENT LAW WORK IN THE CITY
DID NOT GET ALL HEARING PUBLIC
POLICY. BECAUSE IT WILL THE
PUBLIC POLICY ISSUE. UP FULLY
APPRECIATE- THE NOTION OF
ECONOMIES ANY FISSION CITIES-
FROM MY PERSPECTIVE BASED ON
THE DISTRICT I REPRESENT I
THINK CAN TRUMP DUE PROCESS.
AND FULLY HERE MONEY THAT THE
CHIEF JUSTICE WILL BE DOING. I
HAPPEN TO READ. REPORT
CONDUCTED BY THE- NYU SCHOOL OF
LAW THEIR CIVIL JURY PROJECT
THAT TALKS ABOUT UNDERSTANDING
BY US ACROSS THE BOARD IN JURY
SELECTION PROCESS AND
TECHNOLOGY EVERYBODY TO A POINT
WHERE- JURIES ARE TRULY A JURY.
YEARS WERE EMPLOYED BIAS WAY
INTO THAT PROP I THINK IT IS
REQUIRED WORK. THE FULL. IF
CHALLENGES RIGHT I HOPE THAT A
PART OF ULTIMATELY GET SAYS
THERE THE COVERT NINETEEN
CHALLENGES REAL AND I HOPE THE
COURTS ACROSS THE STATE ARE
BEGINNING TO THINK ABOUT TALK
ABOUT HOW THEY'RE GOING TO
ADDRESS UP I DON'T KNOW THE
BILL SIGNIFICANT IMPACT YOU
STILL HAVE TWELVE JURORS IN
EUROPE YOU CAN'T THIS. WE'RE
GOING TO BUILD. ALLEN PORTS
THAT AGAIN I HOPE. THE BILL
MAKES THAT BIG A DIFFERENCE ALL
OF WITH REGARD TO A RESPONSE TO
CALL IT NINETEEN AND FOR ALL
THOSE REASONS I WON'T BE VOTING
TODAY I THE BILL. FOR CERTAINLY
SENATOR JACKSON ME SO WHEN THIS
WAS- IN. PUT IN A BUDGET BILL
AS AS THE CHAIR OF THAT
PARTICULAR SUBCOMMITTEE WE DID
NOT HEAR IT AND- WE DID NOT GET
TO SEE A LANGUAGE IN THE
TRAILER BILL UNTIL AFTER CLOSER
HEARING. AS FAR. WORD IN A I
EXPRESSED MY ARM OFF AT THAT
POINT TO THE AND TO THE STAFF
THAT NO CHEATING BUT IT WAS-
FIFTY EIGHT GET THROUGH SO IT'S
OBVIOUS IS THE POLICY. WHAT WE
HAVE ASSIST IT. AND I
APPRECIATE THAT WE REALLY ARE
UNDER THESE AT I WILL NEVER
CALLED PRESIDENT SINCE WE'VE
HAD A PLAGUE PANDEMICS ORBITS.
THEN ARE LIFETIME THIS IS. AND
WE KNOW THE DATE MAKING THE AND
MANY MANY FACTORS ARE. A VERY
DIFFICULT TO DO ASSEMBLY. COOL
IT'S VERY DIFFICULT TO VENTURE
A COURT ROOM RIGHT NOW- I COULD
RESHAPE PERHAPS AN EXTENSION OF
ONE WE'RE JUST GIVEN THE
ENDEMICS DANCE BUT AS IN THE
TERM MISTIMED ONLY HOPING THAT
WE WILL NOT BE IN THIS
CIRCUMSTANCE WOULD HAVE LIKE
EIGHTEEN MONTHS. IF THIS YEAR'S
WHEN WE KNOW THAT WE ALREADY
HAVE THAT WHEN WE LOOK AT THREE
MAKE UP WHEN WE LOOK AT WHO
SHOWS UP. WHO IS STEPHEN
ALLOWED TO SERVE. WE ALREADY
HAVE A SITUATION WHERE OUR
JURIES AREN'T NECESSARILY
REPRESENTATIVE. OUR POPULATION
AS A WHOLE AND SO TO REDUCE THE
PEREMPTORY CHALLENGE. DOES
CREATE A SITUATION WHERE THE
DID IT JUST RESTRICTS THE
ABILITY FOR THE TO HELP ENSURE
THAT THE JURY POOL REALLY
REFLECTS. THE YOU KNOW IF THAT
TYPE OF DEMOGRAPHICS IN THE
FEAR PROCESS SO I. A WOULD STAY
OFF OF IT RIGHT NOW BECAUSE I
WOULD NOT BE COMFORTABLE TO
EXTEND IT FOR THREE YEARS. YES
CENTER MOORLACH. SENSORS A SO
MUCH OPPOSITION NIGHT I WOULD
JUST LOVE TO MOVE THIS BILL.
AND I WOULD LOVE TO HAVE THE
SUPPORT BY REPUBLICAN COLLEAGUE
IN DOING THAT. THANK OKAY FOR
IF I MAY RESPOND YES LAWYERS
FOR A GO AHEAD SAM JACKSON IBM.
I APPRECIATE THE PASSION WITH
WHICH THE- PUBLIC DEFENDER
ADVOCATES ON BEHALF OF THEIR
CLIENTS BUT I ALSO APPRECIATE.
OF THE JUDGES ARE THERE TO DO
JUSTICE. AND THE I DON'T THINK
ANYBODY DISAGREES ABOUT THE
NOTION IT IS IMPORTANT TO HAVE
A FAIR AND IMPARTIAL JURY. THAT
IS CRITICS. AND I BELIEVE THAT
IN THE CIRCUMSTANCES AND THE
WHAT WE'VE SEEN OVER THE LAST
THREE YEARS AND WHAT YOU HEARD
THE PRESIDING JUDGE OF THE LOS
ANGELES SUPERIOR COURT
ARTICULATE IS THAT IN FACT THIS
IS A PROP AS THE US WORK. AND
IF YOU COULD JUST STICK. PRIOR
TO THE REDUCTION FROM TEN TO
SIX. THE AVERAGE NUMBER OF
PEREMPTORIES AN ATTORNEY WOULD
USE IN A MISDEMEANOR CASE WAS
FIVE POINT TWO FOR THE
PROSECUTOR AND FIVE POINT SEVEN
FOR DEFENSE ATTORNEYS. SO THE
DATA SHOWS THAT THEY DON'T USE
TEN ANYWAY. AFTER THE LIMIT WAS
REDUCED TO SIX THE AVERAGE
DROPPED TO THREE POINT NINE
PERCENT. OR THREE POINT NINE
PEREMPTORIES FOR PROSECUTOR AND
FOR PEREMPTORIES FOR DEFENSE
COUNSEL OUT. THERE IS THE
ABILITY IN A CASE FOR AN
ATTORNEY TO REQUEST THAT THE ID
NUMBER OF PEREMPTORY SHOULD BE
EXTENDED SO THIS DOES NOT
PRECLUDE. THE ABILITY TO HAVE
ASK FOR A AND FOR A COURT IN
DOING JUSTICE WHICH IS THE JOB
OF THESE JUDGES. OUR TO A LOT
OF FOR A PEREMPTORIES. THE
NOTION THAT. WE ARE BALANCING
EFFICIENCY AGAINST JUSTICE IS
JUST SIMPLY NOT ACCURATE BUT I
DO SHADE I WITH FORMER
PROSECUTOR BUT ENHANCE WITH.
WITH THE PUBLIC DEFENDERS AND
DEFENSE ATTORNEYS EVERYBODY HAS
A PASSION REPRESENTING THEIR
POINT OF VIEW BUT THE ARBITER
IS THE JUDGE. THIS IS A MEASURE
THAT HAS OVERWHELMING SUPPORT
BY THE COURTS NOT BECAUSE THEY
THINK IT'S GOING TO REDUCE OUR
JUSTICE IN FACT THAT IT'S NOT
THE CASE. YOU HAVE NO IMPACT.
IMPLICIT YES. YOU KNOW WE HAVE
THE CHIEF JUSTICE'S CREATED A
WHOLE EFFORT TO ADDRESS THAT
PROBLEM WHETHER WE HAVE TEN
PEREMPTORIES OR SIX ISN'T GOING
TO ADDRESS THE IMPLICIT BIAS
ISSUE THAT WE HAVE IN OUR
SOCIETY SO TO TRY TO INFLATE
THOSE TWO I THINK IS NOT AN
ACCURATE WITH OF WHAT THIS BILL
DOES I THINK THAT. PEREMPTORIES
THIS IS CHARLES TO IT WITH ALL
DUE RESPECT TO THE PUBLIC
DEFENDERS JUST AN OPPORTUNITY
TO TRY TO PUSH THAT ENVELOPE-
TO WHAT THEY PERCEIVED JUSTICE
TO BE. AND I RESPECT THAT THEY
ARE ADVOCATES THE ADVOCATE FOR
THEIR CLIENTS WE HAVE THOUGH
THE COURTS. SAYING THE
DISPENSING OF JUSTICE IS NOT
IMPAIRED AND AS WE LOOK AT THE
FUTURE HERE. AND THE FACT THAT
WE ARE IN THIS DIFFICULT
CIRCUMSTANCE WHERE THERE WILL
BE MANY JURORS PERSPECTIVE
JURORS WILL NOT SHOW UP. IT'S
ARE GETTING I'M AWARE OF MASS
TODAY. ARM I THINK THAT THIS IS
A REASONABLE MEASURE I WOULD
LIKE I WOULD SUBMIT THAT WITH
AN OPPORTUNITY TO REVIEW THE
CASE AND THAT INITIAL REPORT
THIS ED. OVER AGAIN WAS DONE IN
THE PARTS OF THIS PROCESS I
THINK THIS IS CHARGED- A DESIRE
TO GO TO. THERE WERE.
APPRECIATE THE FACT. HEARD AS
AND MANY THINGS TO ALMOST ACT
BUT THEY TURNED OUT TO A GOOD.
I WOULD SUBMIT THAT THIS IS
INDEED A GOOD MEASURE. BECAUSE
IT WILL ALLOW US THE
OPPORTUNITY BOTH ADDRESS THE
REALITIES OF THE CURRENT
SITUATION IT ALLOWS FOR
ADDITIONAL PEREMPTORIES IF IN
FACT THAT IS WARRANTED. ARE WE
ALSO KNOW THAT THE DATA ALONE
AND I WOULD RESPECTFULLY
DISAGREE I KNOW PUBLIC
DEFENDERS WILL BRING UP
LITIGATION FOR ANY PURPOSE. IF
THEY FELT THAT THIS BILL WAS OR
THAT THIS LAW AS IT EXISTS
TODAY WAS UNCONSTITUTIONAL THEY
WOULD HAVE BROUGHT AN ACTION TO
TRY TO OVERTURN IT AND THEY
NOT. OR IF THEY HAVE IT IS
APPROVED SO ONCE WE COME OUT OF
ALL THE- HI PER. TEN BECAUSE-
AGAIN I. GET DOWN TO IS THE
FACT THIS HAS BEEN WORKING. WE
HAVE NOT SEEN AN INCREASE IN
THE NUMBER OF- OR THE PEOPLE
GOING TO THE MAXIMUM POTENTIAL
THERE IS THAT OUTLET IF THEY
SHOULD NEED FOR ADDITIONAL
PEREMPTORIES. STUDY GOING ON DO
WITH A MUCH BROADER ISSUE OF
IMPLICIT BIAS AND I BELIEVE
THAT UNDER THIS CURRENT
CIRCUMSTANCE WE ARE NOT
SACRIFICE. THIS IN WAY SHAPE
FORMIN FACT OF. GIVING
OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS THE
PROBLEM AN ONGOING BASIS WILL
ALLOW US TO BE ABLE TO
ACCOMMODATE THE NEEDS OF. THE
THOSE PAST THIS AND THOSE
SEEKING JUSTICE AND WITH THAT I
WOULD ASK FOR YOUR IPHONE.
BETTER WIENER. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR- THIS IS A THERE ARE
FRANKLY GOOD ARGUMENTS ON BOTH
SIDES THIS BILL THIS IS NOT
IT'S LIKE A CLEAR CUT BILL I'M
I'M GONNA BE ROOTING. BILL
TODAY. I HAVE NEVER. TRY I
CRIMINAL CASE SO I'M WAS
THIRTEEN THE CIVILITY I DID. IF
YOU CIVIL JURY TO SO I PICKED
QUITE A FEW. BY JURIES- BY-
PEREMPTORY CHALLENGES ARE AN
ODD THING AND I THINK SOMETIMES
THEY ARE IN MY EXPERIENCE OVER
RATED ONE THEY'LL GET USED TO
SPEAKING WITH A MASK ON. ON
OFTEN- BASED ON STEREOTYPES
GOOD AND BAD I AM VERY BAD-
SOMETIMES THEY ARE SAFETY VALVE
WHEN YOU HAVE A JUDGE CLEARLY
SHOULD HAVE A- BECAUSE AND
DIDN'T DO SO AND THAT HAPPENS
AND PEREMPTORY IS A SAFETY
VALVE IT IS VALUABLE HI. BUT
OFTEN THEY ARE BASED ON. NUMBER
OF TIMES IN MY EXPERIENCE AS A
TRIAL ATTORNEY WHEN I WOULD END
UP. YOU HEAR YOU END OF THIS
USING SOMEONE NEW AND UP WITH
SOMEONE EVEN WORSE. SO
SOMETIMES YOU UP REALLY
DAMAGING YOUR OWN. CASE BUT THE
NUMBER OF TIMES WHERE YOU END
UP WITH SOMEONE ON YOUR JURY
WHO YOU THINK IS YOUR WORST
NIGHTMARE. HE WON I'VE BEEN
GREATER. ADVOCATE OR- YEAH. IT
HAPPENS ALL HI SO THIS PRINTER
THEY CAN BE VALUABLE AS WHEN I
WAS TRYING A CASE I WANT AS
MANY COULD POSSIBLY HAVE BUT I
OFTEN ENDED UP BUT AS I GOT
MORE EXPERIENCED I USED A FEW
HARM FEWER HIS EYES SO AND SOME
HAPPY TO SUPPORT THE BILL TO.
SEVERAL OF THE CORRECT SO WE DO
HAVE A MOTION I KNOW THAT- I
BELIEVE OF A SURGEON I THINK
THAT SENATOR BRADFORD JUST RATE
OF THE ROOM AND HILL HE SAID HE
WOULD COME BACK INTO THE- WE
CAN. CALL THE ROLL. SB ELEVEN
THIRTY THREE DO PASS AS AMENDED
THE WAY LET'S WAIT UNTIL
SENATOR. BRADFORD OKAY GO AHEAD
SKINNER. MORE LOCK MORE LIKE
AYE BRADFORD. JACKSON HI
JACKSON AYE MITCHELL. MORALE
MORALE I'D WINNER. I WIENER AYE
BILL HAS FOUR VOTES IS OUT- LET
US OPEN THE ROLE ON THE OTHER
BILLS THAT DIDN'T HAVE A DATE
WERE NOT. THAT IF WE HAVEN'T
CLOSE THE ROLE LET'S PUT IT
THAT WAY SO FIRST CONSENT
CALENDAR THINK WE HAD ONE
MEMBER MISSING. THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. IN NINE OH THREE SB
NINE TWENTY TWO SB ELEVEN
TWENTY THREE AND- ELEVEN TWENTY
SIX MORALE. MORRELL AYE. SEVEN
ZERO THREE SO THEN THE NEXT
BILL THAT WE HAD STILL ON CALL
WAS- SENATOR. THE RISERS
CORRECT YES OKAY SEVERAL FIRST
ON SB ELEVEN ELEVEN. SB ELEVEN
ELEVEN JACKSON I. JACKSON
ONLINE SIX ONE OKAY AND THEN-
IS BROWSER SECOND BILL SB
TWELVE NINETY OPEN THE ROLE. IN
EVERYBODY WAS THERE EVERYONE IS
YOUR FOR THAT SO WE OTHERWISE
HAVE TAKEN- VOTE ON ALL WE
CLOSE AND SIXTY FOUR YOUR BILL-
IS TEN SIXTY FOUR WHO IS OUT OF
THE ROOM TAX. OKAY ACCENT
COLLEGE SB ACTS AND I OKAY THE
BILL IS OUT 614-803-1064 ZERO
SIX WOMAN AND I COULD NOT ALLOW
SB SEVEN ELEVEN OUT. CRITICS
FEEL SEVEN IS THE WHAT NUMBER.
ONE MOMENT ONE AND S. B. TWELVE
NINETY OUT. I KNOW I DIDN'T SEE
THE NO. THIS FIVE ONE OKAY. X.
THANK YOU. VERY MUCH EVERYONE
ALL OF THOSE WHO PARTICIPATED
BY TELEPHONE ALL OF THOSE
SITTING ON THE DICE WEARING
MASKS STAFF. AND MODERATOR AND
EVERYONE TO ASSISTED US IN THIS
HEARING THAT THAT CONCLUDES THE
PUBLIC SAFETY HEARING FOR TODAY
WE WILL BE HOLDING A SECOND
HEARING- I CAN'T REMEMBER THE
DATE. ON THAT MAY TWENTY SEVEN.
THE HEARING SOME ADDITIONAL
THEN IT IN ME. WE ARE ADJOURNED
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.